que vous vous rappelez de Cookie Monster
certains ouais bah moi c'est pareil
me contrôle plus quand j'envoie
pour être sûr que il y a pas eu d'erreur
dans l'organisation de cet après-midi
qui dans cette salle n'a jamais vu une
vidéo d'une heure de ma pomme
donc c'est parfait donc c'était une très
bonne idée de faire qu'un quart d'heure
peut-être que pour chanter cette partie
introductive je vais même pas m'amuser à
rappeler les enjeux je vais peut-être
insister sur le calendrier
quand on a l'âge que j'ai 2050 c'est
quelque chose qui est
on se dit bon on sera mort où on en sera
tellement proche que même si on y passe
c'est pas très grave pour une partie des
gens qui sont qui sont dans cet
établissement 2050 ils auront même pas
mon âge et on est en train de parler
pour 2050 actuellement d'une élévation
de température qui pourrait déjà
dépasser les deux degrés vous savez
qu'actuellement l'élévation de
température planétaire et de l'ordre de
0,2 degré par décennie ce qui veut dire
que comme on est à un peu plus d'un,2
les 1,5 au train ouvrant les choses
seront mort dans 10 ans fallait passer
dans 10 ans et si on continue sur notre
lancée à supposer qu'on le puisse je
vais dire dans pas longtemps pourquoi
les deux degrés
0,2 x 2,5
[Musique]
on y sera quasiment en 2050
à 2 degrés pour vous donner quelques
quelques heures de grandeur quand même
vous avez un milliard de personnes sur
terre qui habitent dans un endroit où
plus de la moitié de l'année à
l'extérieur c'est un hammam je sais pas
s'il y a des gens qui sont déjà allés au
hammam ici oui les gens qui ont dû aller
à moi j'y suis jamais allé
vous savez que dans un hammam on peut y
rester je crois combien de temps il
reste du reste un quart d'heure une
demi-heure en tout cas on n'y reste pas
la semaine
or les gens dont je parle c'est à dire
ceux qui habitent dans la bande
équatoriale là où il fait chaud et
humide à l'avenir il pourrait faire
tellement chaud et tellement humide que
en fait les conditions extérieures
deviendront mortelles même pour une
personne en bonne santé plus de la
moitié du temps donc là il y a un
milliard de gens qui sont
potentiellement concernés à peu près
vers 2050
toujours à peu près vers 2050 à 2 degrés
vous avez 80 ou 90% de l'air de
répartition du hêtre en France qui a
disparu c'est à dire qu'il y a plein
d'endroits où il fait trop sec trop
chaud pour qu'on puisse encore trouver
des lettres comme on est dans une région
ici pas très loin des épicéas et des
sapins c'est malheureusement pareil en
ce qui concerne ces espèces là qui
aiment pas trop quand il fait
extrêmement chaud
à 2 degrés le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen a perdu 20% d'humidité des
sols au moins parce que en fait c'est en
récent vous pouvez voir que les
mauvaises années en fait l'humidité des
sols elle diminue encore plus vite que
la tendance moyenne
pour toujours pour continuer ou ça
s'appelle le moral Copernicus donc le
réseau européen en ce qui concerne les
observations météo enfin le réseau
climatique européen
a sorti des prévisions saisonnières là
pour cet été qui seront sans grande
surprise en été plus chaud que la
normale bon ça ok
malheureusement aussi alors c'est
beaucoup moins fiable en ce qui concerne
les précipitations mais pour le moment
il voit plutôt un été plus sec que la
normale alors comment on sort de deux
ans qui sont déjà plus secs que la
normale on n'a pas vraiment besoin de ça
en venant ici
l'un des avantages du train c'est qu'on
peut regarder par la fenêtre pour voir
ce qui se passe donc quand vous
conduisez une voiture c'est plus dur
enfin si vous pouvez regarder devant
vous mais sur le côté c'est
il y a maintenant un truc qui me
traumatise un tout petit peu c'est de
voir la quantité d'arbres dont les
branches somitales sont sèches
sans d'entre vous qui n'était pas encore
assez attentif à ce genre de truc je
vous trouve voilà un nouveau moyen de
vous saper le moral mettez-vous le nez
en l'air quand vous vous baladez dans un
endroit où il y a des arbres et regarder
la tête des arbres s'ils ont les
branches somnitales qui commencent à
sécher c'est que ils sont pas bien
partis
ils sont en train de souffrir et que
avec des conditions
identiques prolongées longtemps ou plus
sèches prolonger longtemps bah il
finiront par y passer
toujours à 2 degrés la totalité des
coraux tropicaux sont morts ou la
quasi-totalité des coraux tropiques
consommables et donc avec vous avez une
baisse très forte de la biodiversité
marine des captures de poissons
possibles pour les gens qui en dépendent
toujours à deux degrés
vous avez également une très forte
baisse de la biodiversité
marine parce que le réchauffement est
quelque chose que les petites bêtes ne
vont pas aimer dans l'océan vous avez
déjà maintenant des vagues de chaleur il
y a en ce moment une vague de chaleur
océanique sur notre groupe qui suivent
l'actualité qui est qui est
raisonnablement hors norme dans
l'Atlantique Nord c'est à dire que quand
vous allez sur les sites j'ai pas sorti
de planche aujourd'hui mais quand vous
allez sur un site qui s'appelle climat
realizer ou vous regardez les séries
temporelles
quotidien les températures quotidiennes
et après année de l'Atlantique Nord vous
avez une bande mid max dans lequel tout
est à peu près concentré et puis la
température de cette année qui est 25%
au dessus du max précédent c'est très
très impressionnant
l'écart les quarts à la normale
tout ça c'est
2050 ou avant ce que je viens d'évoquer
donc on est en train de parler donc il y
a plus de générations futures dans cette
histoire il n'y a plus de générations
futures en fait des générations futures
il y en a plus depuis 1992
92 s'il y a des tranches dans la salle
parce que en 1992 déjà vous aviez dans
la convention climat qui a été signé à
Rio
le texte disant que il fallait s'occuper
du sujet pour les générations futures
donc si vous parlez des générations
futures en 92 c'est tous les gens qui
naissent à partir de 93 ils font partie
des générations futures d'accord avec
moi je pense qu'il y a une petite partie
de la salle qui est née après 93 donc en
fait il y a déjà plus de générations
futures il y a des générations présentes
donc on est plus en train de s'occuper
d'un problème qui va concerner les gens
plus tard on est en train de parler d'un
problème qui concerne les gens tout de
suite
et qui va les concerner de plus en plus
pour ceux qui sont vivants aujourd'hui
par le même pas de ceux qui sont à venir
ceux qui sont vivants aujourd'hui
du côté de l'énergie c'est pareil les
nouvelles sont pas beaucoup plus enfin
je veux dire le défi n'est pas moins
grand
on a des il y a des contraintes qui
arrivent de tous les côtés il y a des
contraintes qui arrivent sur les
combustibles fossiles on a sorti au
chiffre projet que tu as une analyse
assez détaillée sur les
approvisionnements possibles en pétrole
et en gaz ou sols contraintes géologique
de l'Europe qui qui dans cette salle on
a pris connaissance
ah oui alors là il y a beaucoup moins de
gens là
alors je vais quand même vous dire très
rapidement de quoi il est question on a
été prendre alors je suis désolé c'est
pas des gens d'ici mais là dedans il y a
peut-être un géologue de Nancy donc
voilà on se rattrape comme on peut
qui donc deux anciens cadres dirigeants
total l'ancien patron de l'exploration
et l'ancien patron de l'évaluation des
gisements plus un ancien analyste
pétrole et gaz de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie et on leur a
donné la possibilité de consulter une
base de données de l'ensemble des
gisements pétroliers dans le monde qui
est tenu par un une société norvégienne
qui s'appelle reichstad energy ils sont
trois dans le monde à tenir ce genre de
base de données c'est essentiellement
des bases de données qui sont achetées
par les pétroliers pour savoir ce que
font leur petit copain d'accord donc
normalement ça coûte quelques millions
de dollars pour voir que bien évidemment
on n'a pas au chiffre project donc on a
obtenu un prix beaucoup plus petit
et on a regardé à partir de cette base
de données qu'elles étaient les
perspectives d'approvisionnement sous
sol contre géologique je dis bien
sous-sol contre un géologique des
parties de production
des 16 premiers fournisseurs de l'Europe
qui sont aussi les 16 premiers
producteurs de pétrole dans le monde au
Brésil et Canada
et le résultat de cet investigation à
laquelle j'accorde beaucoup de confiance
c'est que la production de ces 16 pays
devrait être divisée par deux d'ici à
2050 donc on est toujours en 2050 et il
y a deux fois moins de pétrole
qu'aujourd'hui sous-sol contrainte
géologique alors le grand paradoxe c'est
que c'est pas encore assez de diviser
par deux si on veut bien s'occuper du
climat mais c'est suffisant pour mettre
un énorme pastis dans l'économie
mondiale même si on s'occupe pas du
client
parce que aujourd'hui le pétrole c'est
les camions et les bateaux c'est à dire
la mondialisation et sans mondialisation
vous n'avez pas les vêtements
que vous portez sur vous vous n'avez pas
les casseroles que vous achetez chez
Ikea vous n'avez pas les meubles que
vous achetez chez vous vous n'avez pas
de smartphone qui n'a pas de smartphone
dans la salle
bah voilà
parce que le smartphone sans
mondialisation ça n'existe pas vous avez
50 métaux différents dans un smartphone
et il y en a quasiment pas un seul qui
vient d'une nuit française
vous n'avez pas de lunettes voilà un
certain nombre de gens dont moi du reste
qui ont des lunettes dans cette salle
les verres de lunettes sont pas
fabriqués en France ils sont
éventuellement usinés en France mais ils
sont pas fabriqués en France
et quand ils sont fabriqués en France
ils le sont pas avec des matériaux
français
vous mangez de la mondialisation
aujourd'hui l'agriculture travaille avec
des engrais les engrais azotés sont
faits du gaz le gaz n'est pas produit en
France
l'agriculteur utilise un tracteur qui
est fait en acier l'acier est fait du
minerai de fer le minerai ferme n'est
plus en France il est réduit avec du
charbon métallurgicrostralien donc on
est dans la mondialisation jusqu'au cou
et la décarbonation de l'économie sera
également une démondialisation de mon
point de vue alors ça c'est un truc qui
est important à mon avis pour les écoles
d'ingénieur parce que quand l'école a
été créée donc 1873 c'est ça pardon
alors en 1800 1875 j'ai pu en mémoire
mais en 1800 l'économie mondiale
tournait à 9 métaux
le fer le cuivre le zinc le plomb
l'étain le manganèse j'en oublie trois
j'ai plus lesquels
aujourd'hui l'économie mondiale tourne
avec les 92 éléments du tableau de
Mandelieu c'est-à-dire qu'il y en ait
pas un qui n'est pas une application
industrielle
tous les gens qui sont dans cette salle
et qui ont un smartphone sont déjà à
titre individuel dépendant de 60 d'entre
eux
on ne saurait pas faire un smartphone en
revenant au 9 éléments
manipulés en 1800 on saurait juste pas
ce qui veut dire que le pétrole
alimentant les bateaux de la marine
marchande et les camions et quand la
marine marchande est passée de la voile
au charbon puis au pétrole elle a
multiplié sa capacité dans le monde par
un facteur 100 par un facteur 100 autant
vous dire que c'est pas en revenant à la
voile qu'on va conserver la marine
marchande actuelle c'est pas plus en
utilisant des galériens
avec toute la région avec toute la
région Grand Est je pourrais faire
avancer deux portes conteneurs si je
mettais toute la population de la région
Grand Est au galère
ça vous ferait faire d'exercice moi je
suis pas concerné parce que j'avais pas
ici et bien
j'arriverai à faire avancer deux
portes-conteneurs
il y en a sauf erreur de ma part à des
bateaux de gros tonnage dans la marine
mondiale j'avais si c'est 20 000 ou
donc la la décrue rapide de la
production pétrolière et quelque chose
qui va mettre plus par dessus tête de
toute façon une partie de l'économie
mondiale et aujourd'hui des mondialiser
l'économie c'est extrêmement difficile à
tous les industriels qui sont dans cette
salle dépendent d'une chaîne de valeur
qui est mondiale par construction tous
parce que toutes les matières premières
viennent de l'étranger etc en fait tout
et même si vous êtes garagiste vous
dépendez de la mondialisation parce que
les voitures que vous réparez dépendent
elles-mêmes de la mondialisation
donc d'ici à 2050 je le redis même si on
se fout du climat et on s'en foutra pas
parce que les conséquences vont
commencer à nous faire mal et bien nous
allons avoir un vrai sujet sur l'énergie
reine du XXe siècle en fait l'énergie
qui a faible au 20e siècle le pétrole
c'est pas l'énergie du 20e siècle en
fait c'est le 20e siècle s'il y avait
pas eu de pétrole il y aurait pas eu de
fin de le 20e siècle n'aurait pas existé
vous n'auriez pas aujourd'hui de
smartphone
d'études longues et 6 semaines de congés
payés tout ça n'existerait pas
donc là la
dépétrolisation et la dégazéification
parce que le gaz passerait son pic de
production en 2030 on a demandé au même
avec la même base de données
c'est 2030 en olympique de production
pour le gaz va être quelque chose qui va
être contraint
ou gérer d'accord donc on gère ou on
subit mais de toute façon on va devoir
s'occuper de ce problème là
une formule que j'ai parfois utilisée
c'est à dire soit on s'occupe du
problème sur le problème s'occupe de
nous
mais il y aura pas de il y aura pas de
troisième fois si le problème s'occupe
de nous une des choses qui risque de
faire c'est de faire sauter la
démocratie
parce que quand les temps deviennent
très difficiles c'est souvent le retour
des régimes totalitaires
alors tout ce dans cette salle qui se
dit c'est pas très grave ils ont intérêt
du bon côté de la barrière parce que là
ça passe à peu près quand on est du
mauvais c'est moins drôle
voilà donc c'était c'était juste un
petit apéritif à l'heure de la sieste
pour vous mettre en condition et juste
pour vous rappeler que on est face à des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux j'insiste qui
sont à l'échelle d'une vie humaine et
même moins qu'une vie humaine et même
moins qu'une vie humaine
qui sont des enjeux qui sont totalement
systémiques et qui sont des enjeux de
type épreuve éliminatoires c'est-à-dire
que
si on s'occupe pas correctement de ces
choses là on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut sur l'égalité des chances l'égalité
homme-femme la biodiversité etc de toute
façon le truc ira dans le mur alors
c'est pas parce qu'on fait ce qu'il faut
dans ce domaine là que le reste ne peut
pas nous emmener dans le mur aussi on
peut très bien avoir un problème
tellement grave avec la biodiversité ou
tellement grave avec les ressources
métalliques qu'on va aussi dans le mur
pas de problème avec ça mais voilà donc
en fait on est on est confronté à
l'heure des limites planétaires un
certain nombre d'épreuves éliminatoires
à titre personnel le climat et l'énergie
c'est les deux que je connais le mieux
mais il y en a plein d'autres et en fait
c'est on a un vrai sujet de faire tenir
8 milliards d'individus quand tous envie
de consommer comme des classes moyennes
occidentales dans une boîte qui est
parfaite pour ça c'est ça notre problème
et j'insiste sur le fait que c'est un
problème de la génération actuelle moins
inclure c'est un problème de la
génération actuelle c'est pas un
problème pour les générations futures et
donc je vais finir parce que je vais
être à peu près au quart d'heure en
disant que une des choses que j'entends
parfois et contre laquelle je m'oppose
c'est de dire mais la génération qui
vient elle qui sait elle va s'occuper on
n'a pas le temps d'attendre
d'accord donc c'est pas un problème de
la génération qui vient c'est un
problème de la génération qui
aujourd'hui aux manettes on n'a pas le
temps d'attendre que celle qui vient
elle s'occupe correctement du problème
surtout que les analyses dont je viens
de disposer récemment montrent qu'en
plus il y a pas d'effet générationnel il
y en a un chez les très diplômés très
certainement il y a un effet
générationnel chez les très diplômés
mais sur la classe d'âge dans son
ensemble il y a pas d'effet
générationnel quand on regarde la classe
d'âge dans son ensemble les jeunes
mangent plus de viande que les vieux ils
prennent plus l'avion que les vieux et
ils ont plus envie que les vieux de
s'acheter un SUV et ils ont plus envie
que les vieux de déménager loin pour une
grande maison en télétravail
donc il y a pas d'effets générationnel
il faut sortir ça de la tête c'est
triste à dire mais globalement au niveau
de la classe d'âge après au niveau des
traits diplômés là je pense que c'est
différent je pense que c'est différent
mais au niveau de la classe d'âge il y a
pas que des traits diplômés dans une
classe d'âge
voilà je m'arrête là pour l'introduction
et maintenant j'ai compris qu'il fallait
que je réponde aux questions si il y a
des questions
[Applaudissements]
en fait que les questions soient à la
fin me semble-t-il
parce que vous êtes invités aujourd'hui
en tant que témoin parce que du coup la
scène est à partager avec les quelques
industries les grands industriels de la
région que on accueille aujourd'hui
alors
pour
merci beaucoup
donc merci pour cette introduction voilà
alors je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
shifter aujourd'hui dans la salle et
selon mon décompte personnel au moins un
shifter sur deux codé par coeurs sur le
discours parce qu'il est dans
l'association grâce à Jean-Marc donc
merci beaucoup à vous
mais du coup je vous propose dès à
présent d'accueillir maintenant la table
ronde autour de 3 industriels donc
pour le groupe et cuisiner
et enfin Franck Channay pour charnait
pardon qui travaille actuellement au
groupe Kronenbourg actuellement mais en
fait ça fait une autre trentaine
d'années qu'il est dans la maison
et enfin Dimitri Carbonel qui va être ah
non et Jean-Marc
Dimitri carnet
qui vont donc Dimitri Carbonel qui est
un shifter qui nous vient de Paris
impliqué au niveau national et bon
Jean-Marc président fondateur de carbone
4 mais je crois et de chiffres project
surtout mais
pardon excusez-moi associer carbone car
et présidente du site project je me suis
laissé embarquer
et
je propose de faire la vie review juste
après
désolé
merci
merci à vous d'être présent alors petit
petite anecdote Carbonel il y a deux
aides à mon nom mais évidemment le
problème c'est que de plus en plus de
personnes se trompent parce que
évidemment carbone parce que
ça c'est pas la petite anecdote
ce que je vous propose c'est justement
peut-être de faire un petit amoureux
d'introduction sur qui vous êtes que ce
soit Anne Stéphane Frank vous êtes dans
des entreprises différentes et puis
Kronenbourg je vous laisse donner
quelques instructions pour vous
présenter
ah oui
c'est pas top
bonjour à tous je m'appelle Franck
Charnay je représente aujourd'hui les
bracelets Kronenbourg et donc je
m'occupe de développement durable pour
la brasserie depuis quelques mois ça
fait plus de 30 ans que je travaille
pour la brasserie ils ont des fonctions
de développement de production de
maintenance et beaucoup de suffisations
et donc je suis ravi d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui et par ailleurs je suis
italien mais comme l'a fait remarquer le
directeur de l'INSA de Strasbourg n'est
parfait je viens de Lyon
voilà moi je suis Stéphane foot je suis
chef de deux entreprises depuis 2014 une
qui a fêté son 35e anniversaire l'année
dernière qui est une PME très
industrielle et qui propose à nos
clients de leur livrer des postes de
travail des chariots des convoyeurs on
est très impliqué dans les zones où ça
travaille et j'en ai une deuxième qui
fait de la robotique mobile en fait on
fait partie de ces PME qui ont mis un
pied franc et massif dans la tech et
avant cette période là moi j'ai démarré
ma carrière en fait je suis ingénieur
Arts et Métiers
j'ai démarré ma carrière en tant que
ingénieur propulsion chez Airbus donc
voilà en l'air ensuite j'ai fait
quasiment 20 ans dans les trains j'ai
dirigé des
usines de train chez Bombardier chez
Alstom et ensuite je suis descendu sous
l'eau parce que j'ai dirigé le Centre
naval de naval group à Cherbourg qui
fabrique des souvenirs nucléaires donc
je suis toujours allé plus profondément
je me suis enfoncé
oui bonjour je m'appelle anaïsgen je
travaille pour une entreprise
[Musique]
qui fabrique en France pour ceux qui
veulent faire un joli projet chez eux
alors moi je dois peut-être être la
seule à pas être ingénieur dans la pièce
que j'écoute
fera grand plaisir et j'ai pas du tout
bossé dans l'industrie avant de d'être
faire vendre des trucs
inutiles donc c'est un bon sujet autant
pour être parlé d'ailleurs sur la
réglementation voilà et je suis active
aussi dans notamment dans des dans des
réseaux type action ou 4 0 système
locaux
un sujet qu'on évoquera aussi
aujourd'hui donc effectivement de mon
côté Dimitri Carbonel donc à la fois
j'interviens sur toute la partie
conférence auquel vous pouvez carrément
attends on va peut-être pas mettre ça au
beau milieu du
réussi à avoir des fruits donc c'est
l'occasion ou jamais
donc tant mieux et puis
j'interviens aussi sur la
on va commencer Jean-Marc Le
heureusement il y a de la bonne humeur
parce qu'après ce qui nous a raconté au
début on est plutôt le moral au plus bas
maintenant c'est bon avec des fruits on
retrouve le sourire
on l'a vu effectivement que un d'une
part il y a une vraie problématique
énergétique donc je pose la question de
l'atténuation comment attiré on peut
atténuer notre impact ce qui est
d'ailleurs comme bénéfice de pouvoir
moins dépendre j'ai commencé par cette
question donc à vous où est-ce que vous
en êtes parce que c'est un premier point
de départ en termes de mesure où est-ce
que vous en êtes en termes de bilan
carbone ou savoir où est-ce que vous
avez le plus d'impact en termes donc
d'émission mais pas uniquement sur votre
propre périmètre mais aussi en amont et
en aval ce qui est pas toujours très
simple puis peut-être t'expliquer
peut-être les difficultés que vous avez
par rapport à ça
ok
alors nous on a on avait tenté de faire
un bilan carbone il y a pas mal d'années
on avait fini par laisser tomber parce
qu'on était pas bon on n'a pas réussi et
on a on s'y remis en 2019 on a fait un
premier bilan carbone SCOP 1 et 2 et en
2020 on a 6 ans faire un SCOP 3
et on a été hyper surpris de la des
résultats comme beaucoup de boîtes
qu'ils font je pense on était pas juste
par rapport au volume qu'on peut qu'on
peut émettre mais par rapport à la
proportion entre scope et SCOP 3 puisque
le SCOP 1.2 c'est à peu près 2% je crois
nos émissions 98 c'est comme 3 donc on
aura pu se faire plaisir longtemps avec
le 1 et 2 donc on est bien content
d'avoir fait le 3
et en l'édifié alors les difficultés
qu'on a eu c'est c'est de récolter des
données c'est la fiabilité des données
c'est voilà enfin voilà donc c'est un
premier exercice qu'on va refaire
évidemment pour voir pour voir
l'évolution la tendance mais mais pas
évident et surtout le vrai sujet c'est
surtout qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
c'est surtout qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
maintenant avec des vraies difficultés
c'est qu'il y a des sujets qu'on peut
traiter qu'on peut traiter facilement
nous sur nos économies d'énergie enfin
sur plein de sujets qu'on peut faire
notre emballage enfin il y a des tas de
choses en tous les cas sauf 3 c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué puisque ça
touche évidemment par exemple des
fournisseurs d'électroménager qui en
bossent des fournisseurs de
quincaillerie avec qui en boss voilà des
choses comme ça où là c'est assez
difficile mais d'où cette logique aussi
de réfléchir en filière et en écosystème
et on a besoin de de travailler avec
d'autres avec d'autres gens de notre
industrie on a besoin de faire beaucoup
de pédagogies etc voilà mais en tout cas
ça a été un révélateur pour plein de
gens dans l'entreprise de quels sont
vraiment nos priorités quand on parle de
ces sujets là
voilà donc nous en fait on a commencé
dans les années 2020 par un petit bilan
écoflux qui était fait par l'ADEME à
l'époque et qui était vraiment centré
sur les flux de déchets les flux d'eau
l'énergie et puis aussi les flux de
matière qu'on achète et on a fait un
plan d'action suite à ça qui était
vraiment très centré sur nous-mêmes en
termes d'énergie on a essayé de baisser
nos consommations donc on a isolé nos
toitures on a mis des LED partout on a
remplacé tous les luminaires de nos
ateliers par des LED et puis on a aussi
commencé à travailler sur nos matières
aux achats
ça on a fait ça donc en 2020 on a aussi
fait avec le comité direction enfin les
membres du bord une fresque du climat
qui était très intéressante et là on a
décidé
d'enclencher on va dire la deuxième sur
le sujet on sait d'ailleurs doté d'une
ressource expérimentée dans le domaine
de la RSE on a décidé de faire
d'organiser un vrai bilan carbone qui va
avoir lieu là dans les prochaines
semaines et effectivement jusqu'au SCOP
et on veut avoir un vrai un vrai plan
d'action avec des indicateurs même si on
commence parce que c'est compliqué mais
même si on commence petit on veut
absolument avoir une feuille de route
claire qui ce qui se drive par des
indicateurs pour pour apporter notre
part ce qu'on a fait aussi c'est qu'on a
on a incité nos gens la voiture
électrique on a mis des bornes
électriques dans dans l'usine et en fait
on a un système de cartes qui marche
vraiment très bien les gens peuvent
venir se fournir va recharger leur
voiture à l'usine voilà
oui peut-être je voulais en rebondir
vis-à-vis de Jean-Marc par rapport à ça
est-ce que justement tu côtoies pas mal
d'entreprises notamment industrielles
est-ce que tu as peut-être des peut-être
des conseils ou plutôt des avis par
rapport justement sur la démarche
d'empruntes en particulier sur le SCOP 1
2 on l'a vu mais surtout le scope 3
c'est
si je réponds à la question ça veut dire
que Cronenbourg n'a rien à dire sur
l'empreinte carbone si
je peux tenir une heure
non mais moi j'ai déjà parlé tout à
l'heure
la difficulté qui a eu au moment où
bilan carbone a été mis au point c'est
qu'il y a eu deux démarches
parallèles de l'autre la censure
il y a eu d'autres
je te tiens comme ça mais ça va
fonctionner
si c'est bon là
bon
oui donc je disais la difficulté c'est
que au moment où le bilan carbone a été
mis au point par votre serviteur il y
avait dans le même temps une coalition
américaine
qui était emmené par le World Resort se
situe et puis un des bigfort je me
rappelle plus lequel qui a mis au point
un truc qui s'appelle le gag protocole
et en fait ils ont à peu près rien dit
sauf qu'ils ont créé cette notion de
Scop
qui n'avait pour moi strictement aucun
intérêt et je vais vous dire pourquoi la
le bilan carbone c'est une approche de
type dépendance et c'est une approche
par les processus donc je regarde tous
les processus qu'il y a dans une
entreprise acheter des matières
premières avoir une logistique faire
venir ses salariés expédié les produits
être capable d'assurer un confort
thermique à l'intérieur du bâtiment être
capable d'avoir l'énergie qui permet de
faire tourner les machines s'il y en a
etc et même par exemple dans les achats
de matières premières j'avais discriminé
ce qui permet de faire le produit de ce
qui permet de faire son emballage parce
que le destin est pas du tout le même et
les contraintes ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes la raison pour laquelle j'avais
résonné par processus elle est double la
première c'est parce que tout processus
dans une entreprise il y a une personne
pour le gérer partir du moment où le
processus est nécessaire à l'entreprise
il y a une personne pour le gérer une
personne s'occupe de la logistique il y
a une personne qui s'occupe du fait que
les gens viennent au travail à la RH etc
et donc à partir du moment où il y a une
personne pour gérer le processus il y a
une personne que vous pouvez mettre en
responsabilité si vous avez l'intention
de changer quelque chose
et la deuxième
élément c'est que dans cette affaire le
bilan carbone était un lien de
dépendance aux émissions donc je me
contrefoutis de savoir si les émissions
étaient juridiquement la propriété ou
pas de l'entreprise à partir du moment
où elle en dépend il y a à la fois un
facteur de risque et un facteur
d'opportunité le facteur de risque c'est
6 si les émissions chez les autres ne
sont plus faisable par exemple j'ai
besoin d'un fournisseur d'acier et dans
le pays où il fournisseur d'acier on
commence à faire des misères aux gens
qui mettent du CO2 et ben à ce moment ça
je vais en voir la traduction dans mon
entreprise même si je n'ai pas la
propriété juridique des émissions
correspondantes et à l'inverse il peut y
avoir une opportunité par exemple je
vends des produits qui émettent du CO2 à
l'usage typiquement des cuisinières
parce que si elles sont à gaz elles
émettent directement si elles sont
électriques indirectement avec la
production électrique
et à ce moment le fait que j'en dépende
crée une opportunité si j'arrive à
trouver des produits qui émettent moins
à l'usage parce que comme ça je me dis
si jamais il y a une contrainte mise à
l'émission de CO2 c'est exactement ce
qui est en train de se passer avec les
voitures électriques c'est typiquement
le typiquement ce genre de raisonnement
et bien je serai mieux positionné avec
mes produits qui mettent moins si jamais
il y a une contrainte sur les émissions
côté consommateurs donc en fait le Bilan
Carbone d'entrée de jeu c'est une
approche par processus risquée
opportunité le gag protocole comme il
s'était mis à 40 autour de la table
avant de décider ce qu'ils allaient
faire il s'est passé ce qui se passe
partout dans un groupe humain quand
d'abord vous vous réunissez et ensuite
vous vous demandez ce que vous allez
faire ça vaut pour le choix du
restaurant comme ça vaut pour le choix
d'une méthode c'est qu'au bout de deux
heures vous êtes toujours pas décidé non
et c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
donc ils ont décidé que d'un truc c'est
on va faire ce copain 2 et 3 voilà il
savait toujours Pascal alors ce copain
c'était les émissions directes de
l'entreprise comme deux les émissions de
l'électricité et de la chaleur qu'elle
achète et ce que tu crois tout le reste
mais il y avait pas d'autres logiques à
ça ou plus exactement il y avait qu'une
logique vaguement juridique c'est-à-dire
ce copain c'est ce qui est à moi et ce
scope 2 et 3 c'est ce qui est aux autres
mais ça vous dit toujours pas ce que
vous en faites
et comme le GHG protocole avait une
notoriété beaucoup plus importante que
le bilan carbone de l'ADEME en fait il
s'est passé que le gag protocole a gagné
la bataille de com mais le bilan carbone
a failli par gagner la bataille métaux
d'eau parce que la norme ISO qui a fini
par avoir lieu sur l'empreinte carbone
d'une organisation a repris la
nomenclature du bilan carbone et du
reste le gag protocole qui participait
au groupe de discussion à l'ISO a piqué
la nomenclature et on a fait le gag
protocole Supply Chain qui reprend très
exactement la nomenclature du bilan
carbone mais qui était une approche
fondamentale pourquoi je vous dis tout
ça parce que ça veut dire que de ne
faire que le scope 1 et 2 en fait c'est
quelque part s'arrêter au milieu du gué
c'est à dire respecter une logique qui
n'a pas de sens qui est une logique
juridique de propriété des émissions
mais en fait si je raisonne moi en
termes de risque et d'opportunités ce
qui est le raisonnement qu'on doit
normalement avoir dans une entreprise en
fait il y a pas de raison de s'arrêter
au scope 1 et 2 sauf à rentrer dans une
bataille qui est c'est vos émissions
donc vous êtes coupable si elles sont
grosses mais voilà ok mais ça dit
toujours pas grand chose sur ce qu'on
doit faire
pas avoir de très grosses émissions
directes et avoir du mal à les réduire
de très petites émissions directes et
extrêmement dépendants des émissions
indirectes si vous avez une boîte qui
fait des repas vegan livrés à vélo pour
une compagnie aérienne parce qu'appa et
de saturent qu'il est pas gros et vous
êtes dépendant jusqu'au cou du pétrole
donc le fait de ne pas regarder le SCOP
c'est quelque chose qui voilà on a perdu
beaucoup de temps avec ces histoires de
Scop
qui a été mis au point par le GHG
protocole c'est un peu dommage alors
j'en fais pas une affaire de problèmes
d'ego dans cette histoire mais je
réinsiste sur le fait que le bilan
carbone est une approche par processus
et avec une vocation opérationnelle
puisque dès qu'on a des processus on a
des gens pour s'en occuper
alors je vais reprendre partout Franck
justement en termes de levier tu as
certainement fait effectivement aussi un
bilan carbone comme un deux et trois
quel a été les leviers les plus faciles
et peut-être les leviers aussi ou les
domaines qui sont les plus compliqués
les plus difficiles à faire bouger sans
Columbo alors je vais essayer
modestement d'illustrer le propos donc
nous avons
évalué nos émissions carbone sur
l'ensemble de nos trois scopes la
brasserie je sais pas si vous la
connaissez Obernai on a un centre de
production unique en France 6 millions
d'hectos c'est seulement 8% de nos
émissions carbone alors que c'est une
bière sur 4 buts en France et c'est
seulement 8% de nos émissions le reste
et bien c'est le SCOP 3 avec
principalement le packaging même si on a
un packaging très vertueux sur la partie
CHR avec les fûts on utilise en France
beaucoup de bouteilles à usage unique et
donc ça ça pèse très lourd 59% de notre
empreinte carbone ensuite c'est
l'agriculture 17% ensuite les transports
14%
même si on a un transport par train très
développé sur notre brasserie et voilà
pour nos enjeux et là où sont nos
émissions
vous voyez c'est assez facile ou
inversement compliqué effectivement à
faire bouger
tout ce qui est
consommation d'énergie toutes ces choses
là je trouve que dans nos entreprises
c'est quand même relativement facile moi
je trouve que ce qui est compliqué qui
amène des injonctions vraiment
contradictoires c'est c'est l'économie
mondiale en fait quand on a une boîte on
est on est en face de de concurrents et
moi je vois que il y a des endroits des
sociétés des grands groupes qui
continuent à fonctionner comme avant
voilà qui regarde le prix ils s'en tape
complètement de de d'où ça vient de
l'empreinte carbone et de tout ça et je
crois que c'est ça le plus dur à faire
et ça va être très très dur parce que on
essaye de faire des choses et des fois
on est confronté
on est confronté à des décisions qu'on
comprend même pas tellement c'est fou
parce que on est je sais pas comment
gérer ça c'est ces injonctions
contradictoires là qu'on a c'est
compliqué
très compliqué même
alors Anne est-ce que là aussi il y a
peut-être des points parce
qu'effectivement on fait face
effectivement de plus en plus
contradictoire c'est peut-être à avoir
comment effectivement on peut le gérer
par la suite peut-être l'étape enfin
vas-y nous dans les sujets qui qui nous
coûtent beaucoup en carbone il y a
l'usage des produits et notamment des
produits électroménagers qu'on se vend
puisqu'on cuisine en général et donc on
a des on a des sujets assez intéressants
sur lesquels on peut travailler sur
évidemment des produits moins
énergivores mais aussi de dire si je les
achetais pas de nouveaux produits et si
je proposais des produits recyclés si je
vais aussi si je les réparer davantage
etc donc on a beaucoup de sujets qu'on
travaille sur la recyclabilité la
réparation etc et donner une nouvelle
vie à ses produits y compris des
produits meubles etc après je reviens
peut-être sur les injonctions
contradictoires
un des sujets je trouve qu'ils sur
lesquels on essaie de bosser c'est
comment est-ce qu'on mobilise les
équipes et internes et nos clients nos
partenaires sur tous ces sujets dans une
carbone
parce que parce que c'est un vrai sujet
c'est à dire que de mobiliser les
équipes mobiliser nos équipes sur tous
ces sujets on évite dans des débats qui
sont est-ce que tu veux de la
décroissance ou est-ce que tu veux
sauver l'entreprise on évite sur cette
débats qui ont pas de sens donc c'est
d'essayer de garder des messages
motivants pour les équipes en disant
justement ça relève des tas
d'opportunités aussi intéressantes de
dire si on doit croître c'est parce
qu'on doit remplacer quelque chose qui
est moins vertueux etc enfin décidé
d'amener des logiques un petit peu
différentes et ça prend du ça prend du
temps mais c'est aussi une façon on
essaie de trouver des façons positives
d'années le sujet sinon on peut très
vite être dans l'inaction parce qu'on se
dit bah oui mais si je fais ça il y a un
truc tellement énorme à côté ça sert à
rien et puis mes concurrents asiatiques
ou allemands ils font toute façon de la
merde alors à quoi ça sert que j'essaie
de virtuelle etc donc on essaie d'être
de pas rentrer dans ce dans ce débat
mais d'être plutôt mobilisateur sur des
choses positives en fait Jean-Marc
justement parce que on fait face donc
assez on voit ces injonctions
contradictoires qui d'un côté bon bah
faut croître ou au moins en tout cas
générer un minimum de chiffre d'affaires
et surtout de rentabilité puis de
l'autre côté on doit avoir un impact
environnemental comment concilier
justement les deux et quels sont les
expériences que tu as par rapport à ça
c'est des injonctions qui existent
partout et il faut voir que toute
entreprise est un projet de conquête
donc
[Musique]
toute entreprise est un projet de
conquête donc d'envisager une
contraction de sa propre activité c'est
un truc qu'on aime jamais faire parce
que à partir du moment où on peut pas à
la fois dire faut que les gens ils
soient content de travailler dans leur
entreprise fier de leur entreprise mais
le produit qui font etc et leur dire
derrière et vous allez en faire de moins
en moins il y a quelque chose de
fondamentalement antagoniste là-dedans
donc malheureusement il n'y a pas
tellement d'autres solutions si on doit
faire une mutation à large échelle que
dire qu'il va y avoir des gagnants et
des perdants que les perdants il faut
savoir à l'avance qui c'est il faut
savoir qu'ils vont perdre et il faut
être capable de les traiter c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé
historiquement quand il y a eu des
grands orientations
alors si on regarde si on regarde
l'économie à large échelle où sont les
gagnants ou sur les perdants si on se
lance à fond dans la décarbonation les
gagnants sont plutôt du côté des gens
qui s'occupent des infrastructures parce
qu'il va falloir qu'on investisse
considérablement plus pour refaire tout
un tas de trucs qui ont été soit fait de
travers soit qu'il faut compléter qu'il
s'agisse des logements des réseaux des
réseaux de transport des du système
électrique etc et malheureusement pour
mes voisins de gauche les perdants sont
plutôt du côté des biens de consommation
parce que à partir du moment où on peut
pas travailler deux fois la même heure
ou dépenser deux fois le même euro bah
si on met plus de force de travail et
plus de moyens économiques dans la
transformation ou la réflexion des
infrastructures on en mettra
nécessairement moins dans la production
de chaussettes et de bières voilà
à l'arrivée ça doit boucler quoi
c'est voilà alors après là là où on a le
donc ça c'est le truc un peu un peu
large je vais finir par le problème très
pratique qui a été posé sur la question
de la concurrence mondiale parce que ça
c'est un c'est quand même un énorme
sujet
la deuxième chose
c'est que
cette injonction contradictoire à un
moment elle va quand même se résoudre
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
volontairement ou à volontairement
puisque les certains flux physique
certains de flux physique vont de toute
façon décroître
d'accord donc il y a pas tellement
d'états à avoir sur est-ce qu'il faut
souhaiter ou pas souhaiter la
décroissance déjà on souhaite la
décroissance des émissions de CO2 qui
est un flux physique on souhaite la
décroissance de la consommation
d'énergie fossiles qui va de toute façon
décroître même si on ne souhaite pas en
ce qui concerne le pétrole et le gaz
donc ça c'est un flux physique aussi
donc il y a une question de décroissance
qui est pardonnez-moi de vous amener des
mauvaises nouvelles mais sur certaines
choses aussi inexorable que
vieillissement qui est pas plus
sympathique mais qu'on gère quand même
le son propre
donc c'est voilà il y a un moment où il
va falloir qu'on comprenne nos
responsabilités le vrai sujet
effectivement c'est le fait de d'innover
sans mourir donc en fait le gros
problème dans le monde économique c'est
d'être suffisamment en avance mais pas
trop parce que sinon on meurt
donc c'est d'être juste là où il faut
être pour juste là où il faut être
pardon pour que si la société se donne
une contrainte globale on fasse partie
des gens qui vont survivre mais pas y
aller trop tôt parce que sinon avec les
règles du jeu existantes on coule et
effectivement aujourd'hui la société
commerciale reste une société dont le
profil pour laquelle le profil est une
obligation légale c'est comme ça
donc on peut pas dans un monde en
contraction avoir tout le monde qui est
en expansion c'est arithmétiquement
impossible donc j'insiste un des sujets
de société difficiles qui est devant
nous ça va être d'identifier de traiter
les perdants voilà il va falloir faire
alors dans une société
est en moyenne actionnaire je peux le
dire il y a deux choses distinctes il y
a l'actionnaire et le salarié le perdant
important à traiter c'est le salarié
l'actionnaire s'il a bien lu le contrat
avec les petites lignes il a compris
qu'il pouvait toujours tout perdre à
tout moment donc il perd et c'est la vie
je le dis en étant actionnaire moi-même
donc c'est voilà les deux sont très très
différents et ce qui est vraiment très
important de traiter c'est les gens
qui ont besoin de ce revenu pour vivre
voilà il faut être très attentif à ça
mais il va y avoir des perdants on a
déjà su traiter des perdants dans notre
pays c'est jamais très drôle mais voilà
les gens qui étaient dans le charbon les
gens qui étaient dans enfin voilà il y a
un certain et on a traité énormément de
perdants sur les 60 dernières années qui
sont les agriculteurs
les agriculteurs représentaient un tiers
de la force de travail dans ce pays en
1945 aujourd'hui c'est 1,5%
. d'accord donc voilà je sais pas si ça
a été très drôle ou pas très drôle pour
eux aujourd'hui ils font enfin leur
descendants font autre chose où ils font
autre chose bah il va falloir que
de nouveau à l'échelle d'une génération
il y ait des grands déplacements dans
les types d'emploi et c'est un truc qui
doit s'organiser
oui effectivement il y a aussi une
question pour les entreprises
d'anticipation entre d'un côté je
continue comme j'ai l'habitude de faire
si vous alors c'est dans les années 80
il y a eu les chirurgies qui c'est comme
pris des sacrés murs évidemment si on
l'applique l'acide orgie sur l'ensemble
de l'économie ça va être un peu
compliqué donc c'est vrai que les
entreprises lorsqu'elles disent enfin
première possible
je fonce dans les murs ou deux je réduis
potentiellement aussi bien effectivement
mes émissions de CO2 j'apprends à
m'adapter mais potentiellement aussi en
allant vers des services sont décarbonés
etc il y a plus de chances de survie
parce que l'objectif de l'entreprise
malgré tout c'est ça et là-dessus il y a
un enjeu je Franck aussi je voulais
intervenir par rapport à ça c'est que on
voit et on commence à avoir des pénuries
d'eau ou des pénuries de matières
premières qui mettent en péril les
entreprises elles-mêmes Cronenbourg va
peut-être commencer à y faire face dans
le domaine de l'eau pas encore mais ça
vient et l'autre chose c'est que ce que
vous avez mis en place justement pour
vous y adapter
par rapport à l'ensemble des ressources
mais on est comme tout le monde
confronté à une limite aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de pénurie majeure parce que on
bâtit des contrats de partenariats assez
importants avec nos fournisseurs et
surtout on
engage tout un tas d'actions pour
réduire nos besoins donc sur l'énergie
on a diminué par exemple nos besoins
d'énergie de 30% sur les 20 dernières
années sur l'eau les abaissés de 20% sur
les cinq dernières années donc on est en
constante recherche de progrès et
d'amélioration
sur les changements plus structurels je
vous ai dit que 59% de notre empreinte
carbone c'était le packaging clairement
le packaging dans 10 15 20 ans ça sera
pas celui d'aujourd'hui donc là il faut
travailler à ce sur deux plans un autre
scop3 c'est le SCOP 1 le SCOP 2 de nos
fournisseurs de bouteilles et de boîtes
donc il faut qu'il progressent et puis
le deuxième chose c'est est-ce que nous
on peut proposer autre chose aux
consommateurs un autre mix qui soit
moins avec une empreinte carbone moins
importante
avec effectivement
la consigne on n'a pas le temps j'en ai
pour des heures à parler de consignes
ça paraît extrêmement facile la consigne
mais encore une fois on n'a pas le temps
de traiter ça ici je suis très très
impliqué je pense que je passe 50 % de
mon temps sur la consigne donc je peux
en parler assez longuement mais c'est
pas si simple que ça il y a un point
notamment qui est intéressant qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure il faut environ 3 litres
d'eau pour faire un litre de bière
que ce que vous faites de l'eau donc que
vous puissiez dans effectivement des
nappes phréatiques que ce que vous en
faites après donc la brasserie d'Obernai
est là où elle est parce que il y a la
phréatique d'Alsace qui est la plus
grande d'Europe
donc quand la brasserie a commencé en
1969 il nous fallait à peu près 10 12
litres fallait pomper 10 12 litres pour
embouteiller un litre de bière
et c'est toujours le cas pour les
brasseries qui démarrent aujourd'hui
pour les microbrasseries on a énormément
progressé on récupère on recycle etc et
aujourd'hui on est à 3,6 litres sur ces
3,6 litres un litre dans la bière le
reste on a une station d'épuration
depuis le début de notre brasserie et
l'ensemble donc les 2,6 restants c'est
traité c'est purifier et c'est rendu à
la nature dans la dans la rivière qui
passe derrière la brasserie pour autant
je pense que tout le monde a pris
conscience l'été dernier que la
ressource en eau ça venait vraiment
compliqué on était assis en Alsace sur
une nappe réputée
infinie là je pense que l'été dernier il
y a eu un déclic parce que certains
villages en Alsace ont commencé à
manquer d'eau donc on continue nous tous
nos efforts et l'Agence de l'Eau la
prenant etc qui sont les organismes en
charge en Alsace mettent en place des
des actions des aides à l'investissement
pour qu'on continue à progresser et
l'enjeu pour finir ça va être de
réutiliser justement ces eaux usées une
fois qu'elles sont traitées purifiées
pour
en faire quelque chose dans la brasserie
en général sur des actions techniques de
refroidissement d'installation etc c'est
là qu'on voit effectivement qu'on peut
avoir des contraintes dures qui font que
même potentiellement dans quelques
années on puisse pas produire autant que
ce qu'on avait prévu à cause de ça alors
justement Anne donc Stéphane est-ce que
justement sur l'adaptation est-ce que un
vous faites face à des certaines
pénuries ou des hausses de prix un peu
ou des envolés de prix et comment est-ce
que vous faites ça alors on a tous connu
les périodes d'inflation enfin récentes
forcément
alors les adresses de plusieurs façons
on les adresses déjà dans la relation
qu'on a avec les fournisseurs on est
labellisé depuis pas de temps relation
fournisseur et achat responsable parce
qu'on pense qu'ils ont autant de place
dans la chaîne de valeur que nos clients
donc dans les périodes un petit peu
tendues ça nous a plutôt aidés puisque
ils ont ça mieux traiter les gens qui
les payent correctement et qu'il est
très correctement donc au-delà du
carbone pendant quelle relation on a
avec eux et c'est surtout c'est aussi
ses relations qui permettent d'être dans
d'autres dans d'autres discussions avec
eux justement sur l'impact carbone le
nôtre mais le leur aussi comment est-ce
qu'ils peuvent comment est-ce qu'on peut
reconcevoir des produits ensemble
comment est-ce qu'on peut en imaginer
d'autres ça nous permet notamment
d'avoir la discussion packaging de
travailler sur de d'avoir fait des gros
projets pour supprimer par exemple tout
le plastique je faisais des contenants
on utilise beaucoup de cartons par
exemple c'est pas forcément génial non
plus dans l'esprit le plastique on
commence à tresser les nouvelles gammes
de produits avec des contenants qui sont
récupérables etc dans une logistique qui
permet de le faire enfin etc donc sur
les fournisseurs il y a on n'a pas de
pénurie à date mais c'est des sujets qui
vont arriver forcément et après on a
d'autres sujets aussi sur les sur
comment est-ce qu'on fait en sorte que
la qu'on puisse avoir une économie plus
circulaire sur nos matières premières
notamment alors il y a une des familles
de produits pour nous qui est assez
simple c'est le panneau de particules
parce qu'on peut les récupérer en
déchetterie grâce à votre maison
maintenant et ils sont
[Musique]
n'arrivera pas tout seul quoi voilà donc
c'est important ça voyez ce qui signifie
d'ailleurs que il faut anticiper la
possibilité d'avoir une forte réduction
notamment en termes de production et
donc d'avoir une entreprise qui soit
capable d'être pérenne malgré cette
chute voir cette décroissance
effectivement les chiffres d'affaires
oui Stéphane oui en fait ce que ce que
je voulais rajouter c'est que nous on a
beaucoup travaillé nos composants parce
que on fait de la robotique mobile il y
a beaucoup de composants à l'intérieur
on a fait d'ailleurs un éclaté de chacun
de nos produits et puis on a on a mis en
vert ou en rouge le nombre de kilomètres
là où on l'a acheté donc on voit tout de
suite où ça va ou ça va pas et
évidemment il y a beaucoup de composants
de type les batteries les composants
électroniques et tout ça c'est
impossible de les trouver en France même
en Europe il faut les acheter en Asie
moi je crois beaucoup en Europe et je
crois beaucoup collaboration
intra-européennes
je pense que c'est une des clés de notre
salut aussi je trouve qu'en Europe on
est extrêmement naïf sur sur ce qui se
passe en termes d'économie j'ai des
exemples de collaboration avec des
sociétés avec d'autres sociétés je pense
que
en ce moment il faut s'ouvrir il faut
arrêter les les chapelles comme on les
connaît en France et on est très porté
là-dessus on travaille beaucoup aussi
avec les Allemands parce qu'on est en
Alsace là
je pense que il faut travailler ces
collaborations il faut s'ouvrir sur
d'autres sociétés il faut essayer d'en
spécialiser certaines et de faire
revenir en fait l'industrie globalement
en Europe un peu complète alors qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses qui sont partis
très très loin et que c'est plus
possible aujourd'hui donc moi je crois
beaucoup en l'industrie de toute façon
je suis en industriel dans l'âme depuis
toujours il y a qu'à regarder autour de
vous d'ailleurs tout ce que vous avez
autour de vous a été fabriqué quelque
part par l'industrie et je pense que
c'est le seul salut de c'est voilà de
collaborer et de travailler ensemble et
puis si on prend l'exemple je pense que
vous êtes comme pas mal dépendant des
semi-conducteurs et
notamment il y a eu un certain de
sécheresses qui ont fait que comme elle
a besoin de beaucoup d'eau pour produire
des semi-conducteurs ça exacerber
effectivement les pénuries il se pose
évidemment aussi la question de
l'économie circulaire sans doute de se
dire est-ce que il y a moyen par exemple
sur le matériel qui est détérioré de
pouvoir récupérer quelques éléments pour
le pouvoir le réintégrer c'est ce que
vous faites notamment pour pour vous
alors juste un point je veux bien que si
quelqu'un me dit combien de minutes il
nous reste parce que comme j'ai pas de
montre avec moi vous me le dites
lorsqu'il sera 5 minutes un petit top ça
me va bien
autre autre autre point aussi c'est au
niveau du territoire est-ce que
parce que justement tant qu'à faire
autant faire des choses si possible de
manière assez proche est-ce qu'il y a
moyen ou pas de voilà de créer des
réseaux entre les différents territoires
et en quoi ça peut peut-être vous aider
justement pour éviter de commencer à
s'improviser à l'autre bout du monde je
sais pas si d'ailleurs jean-marin tu
voulais donner quelques éléments
là-dessus
l'enseignement étant un long rabâchage
je vais répéter un truc que j'ai tout à
l'heure
encore une fois on n'est plus en 1800 ou
l'économie mondiale fonctionnait sur
neuf métaux aujourd'hui toutes
l'économie sont une question que je peux
poser par exemple pour tous les gens
pour une entreprise dans la salle qui
pourrait faire tourner sa boîte sans
informatique
bon comme dans un système informatique
il y a 60 métaux vous êtes tous
dépendants d'au moins 60 métaux voilà
déjà
comment est-ce que on fait pour
relocaliser en France la production des
métaux en question on fait pas
parce qu'il y a pas les mines donc en
fait la question de la relocalisation de
l'industrie alors c'est une affaire de
curseur on peut remettre des choses ce
qu'on peut facilement faire c'est
réintégrer des étapes de valeur ajoutée
à la Val De La Mine je prends l'exemple
des batteries dans le domaine des
batteries vous avez peut-être vu passer
dans l'actualité qu'on est en train de
construire plusieurs grosses usines de
batterie en France mais la construction
de la batterie en fait c'est l'étape
finale d'un certain nombre d'étapes qui
part de la mine derrière vous avez le
raffinage des métaux derrière vous avez
la fabrication des principes actifs
derrière vous avez la fabrication des
cellules et derrière vous avez la
fabrication des batteries
l'assemblage final c'est pas ça qui
permet d'éviter beaucoup d'émissions de
CO2 dans la fabrication de la batterie
si on le fait en France parce que le
gros des émissions il est dans le
raffinage des métaux et dans la
fabrication des principes actifs
donc pour avoir pour gagner en CO2 en
faisant ça en France il faut en grosse
situer à Laval de la mine et tant
entendu que il y a des métaux pour
lesquels alors lithium on peut avoir en
France il y en a en France
nickel il y en a en France
politique il y en a pas en métropole il
y en aura un nouvel Calédonie
il y en a pas en France aujourd'hui on
utilise du cobalt dans la dans les
batteries cuivre on utilise beaucoup
dans les batteries il y en a pas en
France il y en a en Europe mais l'Europe
ne produit que 20% du cuivre qu'elle
utilise voilà donc on peut bouger des
curseurs en fonction des en fonction des
voilà il faut pas rêver d'une industrie
qui redeviendrait totalement localisée
en France de la mine jusqu'au produit
fini ça c'est un truc qui dans le monde
dans lequel on vit est strictement
impossible et ainsi d'Amand
décomplexifier les produits ce que
devient appelle les low tech mais en
fait le lotex est beaucoup d'ingéniosité
surtout
parce que c'est tiré le meilleur parti
de pas grand chose c'est ça
et bien
c'est c'est notamment être capable
d'imaginer une façon de fonctionner qui
nous rendent moins dépendant d'un
certain nombre de ressources qui sont
dans des endroits où on maîtrise
absolument pas ce qui se passe et avec
ce que je vous ai raconté tout à l'heure
pendant le propos introductif vous
comprenez que tout ce qui se passe dans
des endroits où on maîtrise rien dans un
monde qui devient plus chaotique c'est
autant de mauvaises surprises possibles
donc on a intérêt à l'avenir à
décomplexifier les produits qu'on fait
et à intégrer un maximum d'étapes de
valeur ajoutée chez nous et ça c'est pas
du tout incompatible avec une forme de
sobriété tout ça tout ça est
parfaitement compatible
je vais prendre je peux donner quelques
exemples ce qu'on a la chance nous avec
la bière de pouvoir travailler peut-être
plus en local que que vous
notre matière première principale donc
l'eau on en a parlé
maltodorge c'est entièrement français
l'orge on a la chance d'avoir une
culture dangereuse qui colle dans le
Grand Est en Bourgogne la malterie et la
Strasbourg les bouteilles en verre elles
viennent de des Vosges et en plus elles
deviennent par train et en plus grâce à
vous il y a 88% de verre recyclés dans
les bouteilles neuves donc tout ça c'est
local et ensuite on a des coproduits et
les coproduits restent aussi en local
nos drèche tout le monde sait ce que
c'est avec les tâches on est en Alsace
donc les drêches quelques dizaines de
milliers de tonnes par an alimentent les
terrains alsaciennes
les vaches la terre du Grand Est pardon
et les levés et les levures sont
traitées au Port du Rhin pour de
l'alimentation humaine et animale donc
c'est possible même à des échelles
énormes comme les nôtres de rester le
plus possible dans la région
non et ni une autre d'ailleurs mais on y
travaille et on espère décarboner la
brasserie d'ici deux ans et c'est déjà
le cas pour l'électricité qui n'est plus
carbonique
Stéphane et
anneaux sur les territoires ou sur
justement votre implication au niveau
des territoires ou le collection avec
d'autres entreprises oui effectivement
sur les territoires nous on a dans le
nord de l'Alsace là on est Haguenau on a
créé un réseau qui s'appelle résilient
résilient il faut être résilient et en
fait on est beaucoup d'entreprises dans
ce réseau on partage un certain nombre
de sujets
y compris tous ceux dont on discute mais
encore d'autres on a beaucoup travaillé
d'ailleurs sur la résilience c'est quoi
la résilience on a travaillé aussi sur
les ressources humaines comment on fait
pour pour être globalement plus
résilient sur nos pratiques managériales
enfin tout ça et ce genre de réseau
voilà on en a monté un dans le nord de
l'Alsace ça fonctionne vraiment très
bien c'est très intéressant
et du coup on a monté le même en
centrale
qui s'appelle
[Rires]
[Musique]
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à bosser
ensemble c'est surtout beaucoup
d'industriels parce que c'est des ça a
été créé par des industriels et l'idée
de se dire permettons à nos équipes de
se connaître que les gens se connaissent
déjà qu'ils aient envie de bosser
ensemble qu'ils ont envie de faire des
projets ensemble on suggère des sujets
autour ça peut être l'attractivité de
talent ça peut être ça peut être du
carbone par exemple on a on a déployé
des fresques du climat dans plein de
boîtes d'ailleurs du coup ça a inspiré
plein d'entreprises mais on a du coup
plein de fresqueurs là maintenant qui
s'amusent d'ailleurs ils font plus que
ça à avoir à faire des conférences
je crois les deux tiers des
collaborateurs qui ont fait une fraise
du climat au moins cette année puis pas
mal commence déjà tuer deux tonnes enfin
bref donc il y a plein d'initiatives
comme ça toutes simples on se dit mais
avant de vouloir faire des trucs énormes
déjà commençons par des trucs tout
simple donnons-leur des inputs pour
qu'ils puissent démarrer un bilan
carbone et on était étonné de voir
quelques grosses boîtes du secteur qui
ont même pas démarré la démarche des
grosses en des gros groupes
internationaux etc donc oui c'est assez
vertueux de bosser en sur le même
territoire sur ces sujets là je crois
qu'il y avait quelques questions de
plusieurs personnes c'est ça ou je me
trompe pas c'est bien ça
je voudrais juste rajouter juste un
petit élément dans l'ordre Alsace qu'on
a fait aussi que je trouve extrêmement
positif c'est que il y a tout un réseau
de pistes cyclable qui ont été
construites ces derniers mois c'est
absolument hallucinant on fait on fait
des kilomètres en vélo en passant dans
les champs et tout c'est absolument
magnifique ça ça progresse vraiment très
bien et maintenant les gens de certains
villages comme vraiment venir bosser
facilement en vélo et je trouve ça super
bien
nous aussi on a épicyclable moi j'ai une
question est-ce que là-dedans il y en a
une partie qui venait en voiture avant
ou avant il n'est plutôt en transport en
commun et plutôt dans la voiture en
voiture
alors je crois qu'il y avait des
questions mais déjà de au niveau de la
salle enfin même avant vous aviez
quelques questions devant me semble-t-il
non ou pas c'est ce qu'on m'a indiqué
alors sinon on va faire simple est-ce
qu'il y a peut-être une ou deux
questions on n'a pas énormément de temps
mais une ou deux questions oui c'est un
homme une femme ou une femme un homme
moi je préfère une femme un homme
d'ailleurs
bonjour Isabelle ice de l'entreprise
Libert que pensez-vous de la Chine parce
que on voit à la Chine qui qui
par exemple le green style c'est on
dirait que ça va être que la Chine qui
va proposer ça va être les premières
proposer du de la cyber la batterie
aujourd'hui tous les matériaux sont
achetés par la Chine la Chine fait le
processing et les revend donc si on veut
aujourd'hui on va acheter de la batterie
on doit passer par la Chine où on veut
produire de la batterie on est obligé de
passer par la Chine et la Chine elles
vont les produits les produits processés
plus chers plus cher du coup même si on
a les achète de la Chine c'est difficile
de battre le prix de batterie de la
Chine donc
la Chine elle a plusieurs
plusieurs chemins une stratégie comme
comment vous le voyez vous avez vous
aussi observé la même chose ou
faire un bout de réponse là-dessus
la Chine en fait elle est dans un combat
à armes inégal avec l'Europe parce que
l'Europe depuis sa création
a eu comme règles de plutôt favoriser le
consommateur au détriment du producteur
donc en fait on s'est donné des règles
qui insistaient énormément sur les la
concurrence qui est un truc qui fait
baisser les prix donc qui est un truc
qui est bon pour le consommateur mais
qui raccourcit les horizons de temps
donc qui crée de l'insécurité pour le
producteur
et du reste on le voit bien en univers
concurrentiel des gens qui investissent
à très long terme il y en a pas tant que
ça tant que ils sont pas sécurisés par
l'État d'accord des gens qui
investissent de façon avec leur propre
capitaux il faut qu'ils aient une
sécurité la Chine elle a elle a à la
fois un régime politique différent et
elle a une philosophie économique
différente puisque elle a quand même
donné énormément la priorité aux
producteurs ces dernières décennies
la seule manière pour les Européens
d'essayer de faire quelque chose c'est
de mettre des normes sur l'empreinte
carbone des produits parce que
globalement l'empreinte carbone des
produits venant de Chine est plus élevés
que l'empreinte carbone des produits
venant d'Europe quelques exceptions près
si c'est fabriqué tout en Pologne c'est
un peu plus carboné que si c'est
fabriqué n'importe où ailleurs en Europe
juste derrière en Allemagne c'est
intermédiaire et après il y a pas mal de
pays dans lesquels ça allait encore
moins mais en gros c'est ça alors c'est
ce que la Commission européenne va faire
sur les batteries par exemple sur les
batteries il va y avoir une norme sur
l'empreinte carbone des batteries en
Europe et clairement c'est une mesure
protectionniste mais comme toute mesure
protectionniste à partir du moment où on
veut protéger son industrie domestique
contre des importations il y a également
le fameux système de ce qu'on a appelé
la taxe carbone aux frontières alors
qu'il y a pas une taxe en fait la taxe
carbone aux frontières c'est un système
dans lequel les importateurs pour
certains produits doivent acheter des
quotas exactement comme les producteurs
domestiques des mêmes commodités pour le
moment ça s'applique sauf erreur de ma
part à 5% 500 sur 10000 ça 5% des
entrées de la nomenclature douanière
donc c'est un tout petit morceau et ça
s'applique à des trucs de base du ciment
de l'acier des composés chimiques de
base etc ça s'applique pas aux produits
manufacturé donc par exemple pour la
batterie ou les voitures ça joue
toujours pas mais il y a pas tellement
d'autres moyens de faire à partir du
moment où on reste dans un jeu
concurrentiel il y a deux manières de
faire où on met des tarifs loyers
ou une protection par la norme il y a
deux manières de faire aujourd'hui
les tarifs douaniers sont
antagonistes avec les accords de liberté
du commerce que nous avons nous-mêmes
signées donc on pourrait sortir de l'OMC
voilà pour leur manière de traiter le
problème on sort de l'OMC et on colle
des tarifs douaniers dans tous les sens
ça finira peut-être par se faire j'en
sais rien et la deuxième manière de
faire sinon c'est on sort pas de l'OMC
mais on met des normes sur l'empreinte
carbone des produits mais ça suppose
d'avoir des vérificateurs ça suppose
d'avoir des valeurs par défaut
c'est-à-dire qu'on dit aux Chinois ben
sauf à ce que vous nous prouviez le
contraire le truc qui vient de chez vous
on estime que ces temps voilà et ça crée
évidemment ce que en économie on appelle
les coûts de transaction c'est-à-dire
que pour une opération commerciale on va
rajouter des coups de gestion de
l'opération commerciale par dessus parce
qu'il va falloir des gens pour faire des
calculs vérifier etc il y a pas
tellement d'autres manières de faire
et puis si je suis certain que en Chine
il va y avoir des industriels qui vont
mettre en place par exemple peut-être
des centrales nucléaires destinées
uniquement à produire des batteries qui
seront destinées à l'exportation en
Europe évidemment et puis évidemment
toutes les autres batteries le feront au
charbon je sais pas s'il soit il voulait
intervenir ou s'il y a d'autres
questions
je voulais poser
oui
après vous me direz aussi en terme
timing parce que là je suis je crois
savoir où est-ce qu'on en est
moi c'était une question on a parlé de
l'eau et de l'agriculture et donc moi
par rapport à ça j'ai une question par
rapport
l'infrastructure et la technologie et en
particulier la désalination et la
culture hors sol la culture verticale
donc c'est pour savoir si il y a une un
intérêt dans cette technologie ou pas si
jamais vous aviez un peu étudié la
question
alors nous sommes pas en culture hors
sol nous avons initié une démarche de
filière on a on a monté la première
filière d'orge brassicole responsable en
France avec soufflet qui a un groupe
français aussi
c'est pas parfait mais ce qu'on cherche
à impulser c'est une dynamique et un
changement auprès des agriculteurs
français vous avez sans doute entendu
parler d'agriculture régénérative il n'y
a pas de norme c'est un peu la
difficulté c'est que voilà il faut un
peu inventer en marchant mais n'empêche
qu'on cherche à régénérer les sols donc
avoir des sols en meilleure santé pour
qu'il soit plus capable de se défendre
augmenter la biodiversité préserver la
ressource en eau en quantité et en
qualité voilà et on le fait sur 764
c'est 10% du des besoins en orge en
France donc c'est massif on rémunère les
agriculteurs pour ça c'est-à-dire qu'on
prend le risque pour eux on les aide à
prendre le risque
et c'est avec des initiatives comme ça
que ça va bouger
et ça reste de l'agriculture normale
dans les champs mais avec des champs qui
sont traités le mieux possible et qui
soit capable de durer pérenne et de
produire pour des années il y a aussi un
petit aparté ce qu'on commence à
entendre parler de désalinisation faire
très attention parce que un
effectivement
savoir des choses qui se font avec
potentiellement
les énergies renouvelables autre chose
donc dit super génial au niveau de
l'énergie sauf que derrière évidemment
on a de la saumure et malheureusement
souvent la semure est directement
déversée soit dans les océans ou dans
des rivières donc faut voir l'ensemble
du cycle avant de commencer à rentrer
là-dedans c'est juste une petite
précision sur le parti agricole enfin
même si je pense pas que ici on se
retrouve concernés mais c'est un point
ici des séminisation alors en Europe on
est déjà très concernés parce que
l'Espagne a construit une très grande
quantité de enfin une grosse capacité de
déstabilisation c'est la manière dont
ils ont réagi face au stress hydrique
croissant et au fait qu'ils ont
spécialisé une partie de leur économie
dans la culture maraîchère
effectivement ça crée en fait il y a pas
de mystère on prend de l'eau salée on
récupère de l'eau douce pour avec le sel
repart dans une partie de l'eau qui est
pas douce quoi donc ça du coup ça
rejette effectivement de l'eau plus
salée
et par ailleurs c'est un processus qui
demande de l'énergie
voilà donc ça ça consomme plus d'énergie
que quand on a la chance d'avoir de
l'eau qui tombe du ciel
ce qui a notre peut-être une autre
question puis après encore en fonction
du timing
bonjour moi j'avais une question plutôt
pour la partie à ma droite
on a parlé de décroissant et je
demandais quel rôle vous vous donnez en
tant qu'entreprise dans cette vis-à-vis
de cet enjeu est-ce que par exemple il
est déjà présent dans vos road map ou
dans les discussions au sommet des
entreprises et est-ce que vous pensez
que vous le jouer déjà et si c'est pas
le cas quand est-ce que vous pensez que
ça va arriver de manière plus importante
c'est une bonne question c'est un débat
qu'on a parlé d'ailleurs en aparté avant
de démarrer le petit tour de table
alors
des croissants c'est un gros mot dans
les entreprises souvent ça fait
vachement peur aux gens et on a
vachement de mal à des mammobiliser
sur le sujet de la décroissance
néanmoins c'est un mot qui est évoqué
dans les entreprises aujourd'hui et
alors au-delà de la décroissance on
parle beaucoup plus de se dire quel type
d'agilité on va devoir avoir pour nous
adapter à ce moment-là comment est-ce
qu'on prépare le mur qui est en train
d'arriver pour qu'on puisse le franchir
et on essaie plutôt de raisonner de quoi
on va avoir besoin pour être pérenne
pour être encore là demain en tout cas
pour faire manger les gens qui bossaient
avec nous tous les jours dans toute
notre chaîne de valeur
et de et plutôt que de raisonner en
décroissance comme étant un objectif on
raisonne de se dire mais comment est-ce
qu'on va s'adapter aux événements qui
vont nous arriver qui peuvent être une
autre pour une autre pandémie des
ruptures importantes sur des matières
des contraintes réglementaires hautes
qui pourraient s'appliquer à nous qui
pourraient impliquer soit une stagnation
soit un calcul de notre activité comment
comment on le gère alors moi j'ai pour
l'illustrer j'ai
en rigolant l'année dernière j'ai offert
monte enfin mon équipe de direction et
cette année je l'aurais pas très bonne
idée j'aurais dû les ramener pour les
signer et cette année je leur ai offert
ralentir au périr donc il y en a qui
m'ont demandé s'il devait démissionner
et c'était pour rigoler mais en fait ils
sont toujours là c'est déjà pas mal
parce qu'ils sont toujours là et autant
il y a des sujets où ça paraissait un
peu une lubie il y a quelques années et
aujourd'hui ces sujets on peut les
aborder je dis pas c'est toujours très
serein il y a des débats houleux sur
comment s'adapte à ce moment-là comment
s'adapte à ses contraintes là et
il y a quelques années quand on
projetait notre vision en tout cas
comment on essaie notre attention plutôt
qu'une vision n'a pas une boule de
cristal mais on l'a on l'a projeté
toujours en termes de croissance de
business donc de magasin etc maintenir
un Rex qui nous permet d'investir et de
développer etc avec un socle de RSE quoi
et aujourd'hui on projette plus
l'entreprise avec une mission qui est
comment va bien habiter cette planète et
parce que notre métier nous c'est de
faire en sorte que les gens et des
intérieurs des espaces de vie inspirants
qui leur plaisent et mais on le met sous
un autre chapeau donc ça change
complètement la dynamique donc on voit
comme des évolutions de mentalité sur je
trouve même sur les trois quatre
dernières années qui sont assez
importantes des prises de conscience
donc donc oui c'est bon on fixe pas la
décroissance comme étant une finalité
mais comme une possibilité et peut-être
une nécessité à un moment donné quoi
mais c'est des sujets qu'on peut évoquer
maintenant mais pas avec tout le monde
il y a des tas de gens encore chez qui
c'est un problème c'est un vrai sujet
même dans nos clients il y a des gens
qui veulent surtout pas l'entendre aux
clients c'est des commerçants il y a
beaucoup de commerçants à qui vous dites
demain je vous ferez moins 10 ça
fonctionne pas bien quoi donc oui c'est
une vraie il y a des vrais il y a de la
pédagogie enfin c'est c'est ça reste des
sujets compliqués
en fait je suis assez d'accord ce qui
vient d'être dit je crois pas qu'on
puisse
résumer ça enfin il y a personne qui
planifie la décroissance dans les
entreprises c'est juste impossible c'est
pas possible donc je crois pas qu'il
faille résumer les choses comme ça il
faut trouver un autre angle d'attaque un
autre biais
parce que voilà on est tous habitués
à vous enfin depuis tout jeune à vouloir
en tout cas nos générations c'est ça en
vouloir toujours plus et il faut aussi
employer des gens enfin voilà je pense
qu'il faut trouver un autre angle
d'attaque et mais c'est une vraie
transformation c'est une vraie
transformation qu'il faut qui va qui va
mettre longtemps et qui nécessite que
tout le monde s'y attelle y compris des
politiques et tout ça donc c'est vrai ça
va être très compliqué
il y a un autre point aussi que
l'entreprise le point c'est pas d'être
croissant en terme de chiffre d'affaires
dans une entreprise qui est croissante
en chiffre d'affaires mais qui qui est
déficitaire ne fonctionne pas en
revanche une entreprise qui est soit
stable ou voire décroissante mais qui
réalise toujours effectivement qui est
rentable c'est l'entreprise qui est
pérenne donc après avoir effectué le
juste le juste milieu et après il y a
aussi notre question qui est est-ce que
je choisis entre une décroissance entre
guillemets subit et ça me tombe dessus
et que ce que je fais ou j'anticipe
effectivement les choses tout en gardant
effectivement une rentabilité quand même
minimum pour effectivement poursuivre
les comment dire que ce soit les
investissements et puis pouvoir payer
effectivement salarié etc mais vas-y
Franck
le débat dans les entreprises il est
quand même compliqué il y a la plupart
des entreprises traditionnelles sont
quand même encore là pour gagner de
l'argent donc mais des gens comme moi on
essaye de l'intérieur de faire bouger
les choses voilà ça va bouger à la
vitesse à laquelle ça va bouger
mais pour moi il y a un triptyque et
vous en avez parlé monsieur Jancovici
dans votre introduction le consommateur
vous vous faites partie des gens
éduqués éclairés et si vous êtes là
c'est que vous avez décidé de bouger
mais 75 % des Français qui rentrent dans
un magasin ils n'ont qu'une seule
préoccupation c'est d'acheter le moins
cher possible donc ça c'est aussi un
point très très important et puis après
il y a nos politiques
ils sont aussi des impératifs en
particulier d'être élus la prochaine
fois et c'est aussi difficile d'annoncer
des virages un peu compliqué quoi donc
c'est un tout on est tous sur le même
bateau mais c'est pas simple de faire
bouger tout ça
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des cours
de macroéconomie
[Musique]
non alors vous vous pardonnerez ce côté
très rasoir et barbant de vous faire un
cours express
quand on parle du PIB parce qu'en
général quand on parle de la
décroissance et la décroissance du PIB
il faut toujours un complément de nom
derrière le PIB en macroéconomie il a
une définition qui est c'est la valeur
totale de la somme des produits qui sont
disponibles à la consommation finale une
année donnée et comme il se trouve que
l'économie ne paye que des hommes on
paye pas la nature on paye pas les
ressources naturelles on paye pas les
martiens ni les gens ni les habitants
d'Alpha du Centaure on paye que des
hommes et des femmes ça veut dire que
[Applaudissements]
elle se rattrape à d'autres occasions
alors
et bien le ça veut dire que le
par définition même la valeur de tout ce
qui est disponible à la consommation
finale c'est aussi la somme des revenus
des gens qui travaillent ou qui
possèdent un morceau de capital donc en
fait le prix de la tout ce que vous
achetez toute l'année ça n'est rien
d'autre qu'un empilement de salaire et
de rente
ce qui veut dire que si on fait
décroître le PIB on fait décroître les
salaires et les rentes alors tous les
communistes de la salle diront bon dans
un premier temps on fait des croix de
cléantes ça c'est facile ok pas de
problème donc on baisse les loyers les
dividendes ok mais enfin à un moment ça
suffit pas et à un moment on tape dans
les salaires donc ça veut dire que un
projet de décroissance sur le strict
plan économique je suis pas en train de
dire c'est bien c'est mal etc ça veut
simplement dire que c'est un projet dans
lequel à un moment les revenus des gens
année après année diminue
donc là je repose la question à votre
avis donc on va parler de l'ensemble de
la classe d'âge je vous rappelle que
dans ce pays le salaire médian c'est
1700 euros net par mois sauf erreur de
ma part
vous avez je crois un tiers de la
population française qui est payé le
SMIC ou à peu près on doit être dans ces
eaux là est-ce que vous dites à un tiers
de la population française mon coco le
projet de société c'est canné après
année je vais te payer de moins en moins
c'est peut-être ce qui va se passer donc
là je suis vraiment très triste aussi
c'est très compliqué d'en faire un
projet aujourd'hui donc je vais être un
peu taquin y compris avec moi-même et la
décroissance aujourd'hui c'est quand
même un truc qui est très en vogue chez
les cadres sub bobo qui sont à l'abri du
besoin non mais je veux dire les choses
de manière un peu cash
en faire en faire un projet de société
auprès des gens qui s'apprêtent à gagner
le SMIC en étant caissier dans un
magasin pour vendre des bouteilles de
Kronenbourg c'est plus c'est plus
compliqué c'est plus compliqué voilà et
pensez-y je dis pas que il faut pas y
réfléchir c'est parce que du tout je
suis en train de dire je suis en train
de dire pensez-y penser que c'est un
truc c'est pas juste un concept
sympathique quoi c'est faire ça pour de
vrai c'est c'est des sujets durs voilà
c'est ça que je voulais dire simplement
et puis après il y a en tant que tel
décroissance c'est vrai que c'est pas
enthousiasmant comme ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir ce qui après
quelle est la société où on veut aller
de croissance enfin c'est un chemin et
après effectivement il y a d'autres
choses potentiellement on peut avoir
plus de bien-être dans un certain nombre
de cas remplacer comment dire le
véhicule par le vélo lorsque c'est
évidemment les infrastructures le
permettent c'est sans doute plus
agréable mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
peut-être évident pour toute dans tous
les cas est-ce qu'il y a encore
peut-être une question alors
alors si on veut respecter la parité il
faut que ça soit un homme
[Musique]
désolé ça va dans les deux sens
merci bonjour
on a eu une actualité assez récente
autour du plastique je voulais juste
savoir comment vous l'intégriez ou
est-ce que vous en étiez chacun dans vos
domaines à ce niveau-là
ce n'est plus fantastique en tout cas
voilà je ne sais pas alors alors
je suis pas une grande experte du
plastique mais parmi mais juste pour
dire on a fait des choix nous en termes
de c'est un sujet qui nous a préoccupé
il y a une vingtaine d'années on a fait
des choix de produits qui étaient
d'exclure au maximum les composants
plastiques ou certains composants par
exemple ou du PVC je fais une extension
pas voilà etc de nos produits ou
d'autres de nos confrères ne le
faisaient pas c'était les gammes les
plus vendus chez nous donc c'était un
choix un peu risqué finalement qui nous
a c'est une contrainte qui nous a poussé
à sortir des produits un peu innovants
qui nous ont qui sont aujourd'hui notre
première vente d'ailleurs donc comme
quoi parfois cette contrainte c'est
quand même vertueux et on a aujourd'hui
plutôt on a des aujourd'hui dans notre
trajectoire
climat et autres un des axes qu'on
travaille notamment c'est le c'est le
plastique là où on a encore le plus
c'est dans le packaging donc on a une
roadmap pour le supprimer complètement
du packaging ce qu'on devrait arriver
assez rapidement à faire et voilà
maintenant moi je peux pas en dire
beaucoup plus à part ça aujourd'hui
en nous dans les angles on n'a pas trop
de plastique donc ça va mais forcément
les gens qui en bouteille de l'eau
minérale ou des yaourts il va falloir
qu'ils trouver rapidement des solutions
parce que la loi GEC elle dit qu'en 2040
il y a plus de plastique à usage unique
donc c'est un vrai vrai sujet pour
l'emballage alimentaire
il y a aussi une réglementation
européenne qui en remet une autre couche
donc il y avait une vraie pression une
vraie pression de la réglementation
française et européenne sur ce sujet et
puis après avoir une vraiment une vision
complète parce que si par exemple c'est
pour avoir du vert et transporter et
puis après Camille est dans un dépôt de
verre et puis pour le réutiliser et puis
après effectivement quand le ressouffler
etc ça consomme énormément d'énergie
donc effectivement là la consigne peut
avoir de sens mais après il faut avoir
un modèle économique qui tiennent la
route parce que le plastique écoute pèse
moins lourd donc il faut vraiment avoir
cette vision globale ou sinon le truc
qui tient pas quoi un exemple très
concret vous regroupez 6 boîtes dans un
papier dans un
emballage en carton votre emballage
carbone elle est moins bonne que du
plastique mais pour autant si vous
prenez du recul il faut supprimer le
plastique donc il faut choisir entre
deux mots c'est pas d'emballage et puis
en plus il y a d'autres impacts on ne
l'a pas parlé ici mais en terme de
biodiversité des impacts on n'a jamais
vu de bouteille de Kronenbourg flotter
sur l'océan alors que pour plastique
c'est pas du tout Colombo ça je sais pas
ok je pensais que ça coulait mais vous
n'avez pas pu la reconnaître l'étiquette
n'était plus en revanche en revanche je
pense pas qu'il y a des nanovaires de
Cronenbourg
objectivement c'est pas très fréquent
juste pour compléter le plastique
aujourd'hui pour donner quelques heures
de grandeur ça pourrait 15% du pétrole
qu'on utilise c'est rien faire du
plastique c'est en très forte
augmentation là dedans il y a un tiers
d'emballage le deuxième poste après
c'est la construction quatre de fenêtres
les câbler électrique les goulottes les
machins etc après dans l'ordre il me
semble qu'il y a les moyens de transport
ensuite je sais plus ce que c'est après
il y a l'électro les objets du quotidien
les manches de brosse à dents les capots
de mixeurs etc mais un tiers c'est les
emballages et les emballages c'est des
produits à durée de vie très courte ça
c'est clair que ça en moins d'un an ça
se retrouve et en dans le monde 50% du
plastique est bien en décharge
d'où évidemment il peut ressortir
éventuellement si c'est mal enfoui etc
et ce voilà et il y a pas mal de il y a
pas mal de déchets sauvages en plastique
ça c'est clair
alors je sais pas s'il reste encore une
question
alors maintenant une femme
alors ah ben voilà vous êtes
parfaitement
tant que c'est une femme tout est
possible
sinon no way
là on est très strict là-dessus
oui
bon moi je connais pas du tout le monde
industriel
mais par contre quand on habite en
centralsace on voit en tout cas la
taille de vos installations bon je pense
à chrono cuisine chimique notamment
alors moi j'ai retenu que ce qui serait
pas mal c'est qu'en fait on revienne en
termes de consommation
carbone à quelque chose qui serait
disons post Seconde Guerre mondiale si
on veut faire d'automne 2 tonnes de
carbone par personne pour moi au niveau
industriel ça veut dire aussi des
beaucoup plus petits ateliers des choses
plus locales donc voilà je me pose la
question en termes de flux est-ce que
d'avoir aussi peut-être des sites plus
répartis sur le territoire est-ce que ça
peut être un levier intéressant et
est-ce que c'est en tout cas des choses
sur lequel vous réfléchissez il nous
reste quelques instants parce qu'après
il faut laisser la place mais allez-y
pour répondre en quelques mots si jamais
vous avez un mode conclusion n'hésitez
pas
une bonne question c'est une question
que l'on se pose régulièrement déjà pour
des questions de coût aussi basiquement
puisque nous on fabrique majorité de
meubles qui sont montés d'usine
d'ailleurs c'est aussi une des questions
Corée interroge puisqu'on transporte de
l'air donc on se demande si l'avenir une
grosse partie de notre valeur ajoutée
c'est de monter des meubles en usine et
on se dit ça devient peut-être un
ensemble donc c'est parti jusqu'en
interroge et on travaille sur des
scénaris justement où on pourra avoir
des sites des sites logistiques de
montage qui seraient plus proche de nos
lieux de consommation par exemple
l'Espagne qui est un pays assez
important pour nous des choses comme ça
et en limite notre développement à date
à une journée de camion donc on dit il
faut que notre matière première elle
vienne de moins d'une journée de camion
et c'est des reviens beaucoup moins en
général et que la livraison elle se
fasse à moins d'une journée de camion
alors on a encore quelques destinations
plus exotiques où ça part par bateau
avec des galériens par alsaciens etc et
voilà mais par contre mais c'est vrai
que c'est une logique qu'on avait
appliqué on avait on avait monté on a
monté près de 800 magasins sous-enseigne
Schmidt en Chine et du coup on a
construit une usine en Chine pour ça en
fait on a dit il y a pas de sens de les
on a fait une usine par contre on a fait
qu'une pour la Chine on est un peu plus
loin de la journée mais c'était des
meubles livrés à plat donc on avait
cette logique de se dire il faut être
plus proche des lieux de nos clients de
produits naturels si Stéphane est franc
parce que là on est un mot et puis après
si vous avez un mot de conclusion aussi
et puis après on va basculer allez-y
quelques mots par rapport à la taille
des unités de production
pour la brasserie c'est plus facile
d'être efficient en termes d'énergie et
en termes d'eau sur des grosses unités
on va être décarbonée d'ici deux trois
ans ça c'est sûr et comparé à des
microbrasseries il n'y a pas photo
maintenant la question va se poser et je
rebondis sur la question de la consigne
tout à l'heure la consigne elle va avoir
un avenir c'est sûr elle va être dans le
mix packaging et là du coup est-ce que
ça aura du sens de tout ramener en
Alsace depuis n'importe quel point de la
France ou est-ce qu'il faudra trouver un
autre chemin la question va se poser
mais c'est jamais blanc ou noir en fait
moi je suis pas tellement concerné par
ça en ce moment par contre chez nos
clients je vois vraiment que il y a une
volonté de proximité dans les dans la
logistique dans les ateliers
donc je pense que on va quand même un
peu dans cette voie aussi de de d'avoir
des centres un peu plus petit et plus
proche des lieux d'utilisation c'est un
peu ce que je ressens je marche je te
laisse le mot de la fin pour conclure
cette assemblée
sinon pour finir de répondre à la
question si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé historiquement dans l'ancien temps
on avait des le facteur limitant est en
énergie on pourrait pas transporter
énormément de choses sur de très grandes
distances donc on avait des unités de
transformation qui étaient très
polyvalentes du coup manipulant des
objets raisonnablement simples avec pas
trop d'éléments dedans pas trop de
composants pas trop d'étapes de
fabrication
c'était totalement sous optimal en ce
qui compte par rapport à ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui sur la les coûts de
fabrication eux-mêmes par contre c'était
optimal au niveau de la résilience
c'est-à-dire que c'était un système qui
pouvait toujours flotter avec peu
d'énergie aujourd'hui on a fait l'exact
inverse c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait des
unités raisonnablement loin les unes des
autres extrêmement spécialisées sur une
étape de fabrication
il y a plein d'usines dans le monde qui
sont des spécialistes mondiaux du truc
qui fabrique et puis il y a qu'un seul
site non mais il y a qu'un seul site où
on le fait dans le monde très exactement
comme ça voilà
parce que le transport ne vaut rien
grâce à l'abondance pétrolière et la la
question de la décrue pétrolière pose de
manière frontale la question de
qu'est-ce qui flotte toujours dans un
monde dans lequel le transport va
devenir de plus en plus difficile à
assurer et effectivement dans ce monde
là la consigne fera de nouveau sens
parce que
ça sera un truc avec un même si même si
ça demande beaucoup de manutention
beaucoup de travail une bouteille en
verre on peut la laver voilà ça coûte
cher parce que ça demande beaucoup de
travail mais par contre ça demande pas
beaucoup d'énergie ça demande moins
d'énergie que de la casser de la fondre
mais mais comme aujourd'hui l'énergie
vaut rien avec le travail vaut quelque
chose c'est évident que l'arbitrage
économique logique il est de faire
l'exact inverse c'est-à-dire de cramer
plein d'énergie pour éviter du travail
à mesure que l'énergie deviendra de plus
en plus difficile d'accès parce que ça
va quand même être ça le sens de
l'histoire à l'échelle du siècle et même
d'une siècle à ce moment ça redeviendra
logique d'avoir des trucs donc c'est la
question que je posais tout à l'heure
comment est-ce qu'on décomplexifie qu'on
despcialistes enfin vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire qu'on relocalise de
manière etc et qu'on raccourcit
l'échelle logistique et les étapes de
transport et qu'on diminue le nombre
d'étapes de transformation pour revenir
à des unités plus polyvalentes et la
question de l'entretien réparation etc
va également avec ça quand j'étais jeune
j'ai su changer un embiage de voiture
aujourd'hui je sais pas s'il existe
encore une personne qui est capable de
réparer elle-même le moteur de sa
bagnole
on va conclure parce qu'on a déjà un peu
manger du temps pour qui suit en tout
cas un très grand merci à toutes et à
tous Merci à VOUS AUSSI pour vos
questions et puis on va basculer ça
[Applaudissements]
donc
oui non pas du tout
donc merci beaucoup à tous les
intervenants de la Table Ronde je les
invite à rester avec nous puisque la
prochaine intervention ce sera celle de
Laura et de Louis
est-ce que je suis allé trop loin oui de
Laura et de Louis puisque certains
d'entre vous lors de votre inscription à
l'événement ont été invités à remplir un
questionnaire un questionnaire qu'on
appelle big review pour connaître un
petit peu vos orientations en quelque
sorte donc une restitution vous est
présentée par Laura et Louis deux
étudiants en génie climatiques et
énergétique à l'INSA Strasbourg et par
la suite il continueront les échanges
avec le public et les industriels et
avant de passer le micro parce que j'ai
oublié de le faire au tout début
d'intervention mais un grand grand merci
déjà Strasbourg pour cet accueil bien
sûr mais surtout à l'équipe qui a
organisé cet événement cette aujourd'hui
puisque en réalité je suis même pas
certain qu'il soit tous là et c'était
même pas forcément ceux que vous voyez
sur sur les strates donc j'aimerais des
applaudissements pour eux s'il vous
plaît
[Applaudissements]
on va se mettre derrière le pupitre
c'est ça dérange pas
alors on va vous présenter une rapide
synthèse du Big review donc il y a un
sondage auquel les personnes qui se sont
inscrites ont répondu sur le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
qui a un rat rapport réalisé par le
chiffre project
donc
voilà alors
au niveau du public qui a été interrogé
donc vous on a une majorité de cadres et
d'étudiants et principalement des hommes
donc on a quand même des profils assez
proches
ensuite donc il y a une question qui
s'est posée par rapport à la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
sur qui on devait viser en priorité donc
il y avait différents choix et donc on
voit qu'il y a une écrasante majorité
d'entre vous qui ont voté pour
entreprise et consommateurs une partie
ensuite non négligeable qui a dit que
c'était uniquement la responsabilité des
entreprises et ensuite on a autre donc
on va quand même que les gens sont très
majoritairement en accord sur ces
questions
alors
le PT EF implique des changements
d'ici 30 ans au niveau des emplois et ou
des métiers et donc la question ici
était de savoir est-ce qu'il est
nécessaire d'anticiper ces modifications
à venir alors principalement remarque
bon il y a une grande majorité qui est
tout à fait d'accord ou plutôt d'accord
donc voilà on ne change pas et puis
ensuite la construction de la résilience
à l'échelle du territoire passe par une
planification
encadrée par les Pouvoirs Publics de la
production industrielle avec une
approche fondée sur les besoins et sur
la prise en compte des contraintes en
ressources donc encore une fois on a
quasiment tout le monde qui est tout à
fait d'accord ou plutôt d'accord avec
ces propositions donc on pourrait croire
voilà que
tout le monde est d'accord avec ce que
propose le Shift et c'est super sauf que
il faut se rendre compte qu'on fait tous
partie plus ou moins dans la même
catégorie socioprofessionnelle et donc
pour changer l'économie française bah il
faut prendre en compte tous les Français
toutes les Françaises donc le but c'est
vraiment d'élargir
va le nombre de personnes qui peuvent
répondre à cette à ce sondage pour voir
justement ce qu'on peut proposer pour la
déconner la décarbonation de l'économie
voilà donc on va passer par enfin on va
on va continuer avec l'échange avec
madame lisken monsieur foot et Monsieur
chambre s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
de revenir à table s'il vous plaît
on a prévu des questions à vous poser
voilà excusez-nous
[Rires]
c'est le come back
oui alors bon déjà bonjour à tous merci
d'être en avoir accepté l'invitation
c'est super alors on a quelques
questions à vous poser mais plutôt du
point de vue étudiant donc voilà alors
j'aimerais commencer avec un phénomène
auquel sera forcément confronté un
étudiant une fois diplômé alors une fois
diplômé le Tillion va devoir se heurter
aux critères qui vont favoriser la
désirabilité d'une entreprise
et donc là je parle j'ai pas envie de
parler de salaire ni de bien-être au
travail je parle de greenwashing
alors c'est vrai que il devient
compliqué pour nous de savoir si une
entreprise est réellement impliquée dans
les dans les dans les enjeux climatiques
aussi il s'agit simplement de
récupération commerciale et donc la
question que j'aimerais vous poser
aujourd'hui c'est qu'est-ce que vous
mettez en place vous pourriez mettre en
place pour assurer finalement cette
implication
et assurer que bon c'est pas un coup de
com quoi
c'est une bonne question et
je pense alors
je pense que de plus en plus les
entreprises vont devoir faire de la RSE
pour de vrai entre guillemets et avoir
un vrai impact parce qu'en fait tousser
tous sera donc ça devient je pense de
plus en plus difficile pour les
entreprises de le cacher alors nous on
avait plutôt une démarche
depuis très longtemps de nous dire avant
avant de parler de toi qu'on parlait pas
de RSE par le développement durable
d'avoir de désirs comment est-ce qu'on
peut prouver les engagements qu'on a
avant d'en parler et on est rentré
pendant pas mal d'années dans des
logiques de certification donc ils ont
14000 ans à 18001 ils ont 50000 ans
enfin etc au moins c'est la seule façon
qu'on avait trouvé de d'apporter des
éléments concrets de preuves dans tous
les cas d'une démarche d'un engagement
etc on est en démarche bicorps là on
attend le résultat assez rapidement
j'espère
l'idée c'était beaucoup plus de dire
donner d'éléments concrets qui sont pas
simplement des promesses qu'on pourrait
faire etc
alors à date on n'a pas trouvé beaucoup
de on n'a pas trouvé bien mieux bien
plus simple que de que d'apporter des
preuves en tous les cas par l'extérieur
entre guillemets par des là ça peut être
la certification
ça peut être des éléments de ce type là
qui peuvent la porter après un autre
sujet sur lequel on travaille aussi
beaucoup avec nos équipes c'est que on
demande à nos collaborateurs d'être même
des ambassadeurs et en fait on se rend
compte que vos collaborateurs vont pas
mentir on peut avoir en gros ils vont
pas dire à vos collats à des tiers et
quand je dis nos collaborateurs c'est
notamment par exemple on a une grosse
communauté d'alternance ou de jeunes
embauchés et c'est eux qui vont plutôt
en parler à des jeunes à des jeunes
futurs embauchés ou à des ou à des ou à
d'autres alternants des étudiants etc
alors dire voilà ce qui est fait
réellement dans l'entreprise etc donc
beaucoup de choses passent aussi par eux
et on compte aussi sur eux pour nous
dire qu'est-ce qui est important pour
eux et on leur envoie aussi la balle
très souvent dans leurs exigences de
dire quoi vous vous impliquez-vous parce
que c'est vachement simple d'avoir des
exigences quand on arrive dans une
entreprise mais c'est un peu plus
compliqué quand il s'agit de s'engager
aussi parfois donc on leur demande aussi
de s'engager dans tous ces projets là
voilà donc chez nous on a on a beaucoup
travaillé les critères de la résilience
en fait parce qu'on a une PME
industrielle comme je l'ai dit avant qui
a mis un pied franc et massif dans la
tech et un des quatre critères en fait
on a défini il y a 4 critères qui ont
été relevés il y en a un qui est
en fait un changement complet nos
pratiques managériales nous on a
complètement changé nos pratiques
managériales mais on le vit au quotidien
en fait dès qu'on a un sujet important
un problème important on constitue
immédiatement une équipe de projets sur
le sujet et on fait participer à un
maximum de monde sur le sujet donc en
fait il y a strictement plus rien qui
est caché d'ailleurs on parle à nos
employés on présente des choses et on
fait présenter des choses assez chef
d'équipe eux-mêmes dans des réunions
trimestrielles donc voilà c'est c'est
comme ça qu'on fait et c'est plus
possible aujourd'hui de cacher quelque
chose quoi que ce soit très content on
peut qu'on soit pas dire on peut plus
dire on fait de la RSE alors qu'on en
fait pas
mais c'est comme ça qu'on vit au
quotidien on impliquant en fait tout
simplement de monde c'est la question de
transparence qui
c'est totalement transparent c'est plus
dans le monde d'avant où il y a un chef
qui disait maintenant tu fais ça
t'exécute et puis ça marche plus du tout
comme ça c'est sûr et c'est d'ailleurs
tant mieux
donc la confiance la question c'est
comment vous avez confiance dans ce
qu'on raconte c'est ça ok trois éléments
le premier c'est que nous engagements
sont publiques validé par le fbti donc
je pense que la plupart d'entre vous
vous connaissez donc voilà vous pouvez
les trouver nous engagements sont là et
on a une feuille de route pour les
atteindre la deuxième c'est que on est
fabriqué en alcool donc l'encadrement de
la communication on sait ce que ça veut
dire et je peux vous assurer que notre
directrice juridique porte la même
attention aux allégations de
greenwashing que on emporte aux
allégations sur l'alcool et enfin le
troisième élément j'espère que je vous
ai inspiré confiance tout ce qui est
écrit en termes de développement durable
sur notre site et que vous pouvez
consulter c'est moi qui l'ai écrit et
tous les chiffres
tous les chiffres je les ai vérifiés et
je peux vous les prouver
je voudrais juste conclure cette partie
en voilà en donnant un petit exemple
j'ai pris un exemple local en plus le
grand contournement de l'Ouest donc qui
a suscité débat
donc voilà je vais citer Vinci mais
c'est vraiment pas contre eux il faut
juste se rendre compte de la démarche et
du problème que ça peut engendrer donc
je suis allé sur sur leur site on trouve
un exemple en matière de transparence
écologique c'est un titre donc on a en
compensation de la construction du tracé
donc le tracé c'est à dire la bande de
bitume de 24 km de 4 voies des parcelles
ont été renaturées ce qui signifie
qu'elles ont été dénaturées en amont
donc défricher par des bulldozers ça
veut dire que toute la biodiversité qui
était présente et donc le plus de
carbone que ça ça faisait c'est parti à
la benne et ensuite pour permettre à la
biodiversité de s'y épanouir
sachant que bon c'est une route une
route qui augmente le trafic routier ce
qui induit une augmentation de la
pollution atmosphérique ce qui induit
une augmentation de la pollution sonore
et ce qui induit une augmentation de la
pollution lumineuse à moindre échelle
et donc voilà c'est une vision
d'utilisation du terme épanouir sachant
qu'il s'agissait d'anciennes terres
agricoles donc je félicite bien sûr
toutes les personnes qui se sont
appuyées sur
le fait de renaturer ces parcelles etc
parce qu'il faut absolument dans tous
nos projets prendre cela en compte mais
ouais c'est la nature même du projet en
fait qui est un non-sens écologique
parce qu'on augmente le trafic routier
et on va habituer on va habituer des
terres agricoles je me permets
d'enchaîner sur la question suivante
donc l'innovation technoolutionniste
elle nous est régulièrement présenté
comme une manière de répondre à la crise
climatique
suffit de regarder l'engouement derrière
monsieur musk et de derrière la fusion
nucléaire derrière la technologie de
captation carbone et de stockage
cette question je la dérivée vers
monsieur faute parce qu'avec Sherpa vous
faites des robots autonomes électriques
qui permettent donc aux personnes
d'avoir moins de charge à porter ce qui
est extrêmement important donc qui se
déplace avec des capteurs sensoriels si
je ne m'abuse
mes connaissances désormais donc les
limites physiques en ressources en
énergie est-ce que vous voyez des
innovations par des lot-tech dans votre
secteur et comment est-ce qu'elle
pourrait s'appliquer juste pour rappeler
les technologies le texte et les
technologies qui sont simples peu
onéreuses accessibles au plus grand
nombre qui font appel à des moyens
courants et localement disponibles
vous en prie
c'est une question compliquée parce que
moi je suis quand même quelqu'un qui
croit beaucoup en latex d'une manière
générale
je pense que par exemple ce que fait
actuellement
Airbus sur les
des carburants
[Musique]
différents quoi que les carburants
typiquement je pense que il y a encore
des des puits de gains justement en
carbone et puis en consommation de
d'énergie fossile qui vont qui vont se
trouver par la tech en tout cas moi ce
que je peux dire c'est que je constate
d'ailleurs de manière parfois aussi
quand même assez effaré comment la tech
évolue dans le monde ça va à une vitesse
absolument hallucinante dans la
robotique mobile on en parle au début on
pensait que
on saurait tout gérer par nous-mêmes etc
mais quand on voit comment la tech
évolue autour de nous c'est juste
impossible ça va une vitesse absolument
hallucinante alors j'ai pas la solution
mais tout va à une vitesse absolument
hallucinante et
bon je reste quand même quelqu'un
d'optimiste c'est un peu moins c'est une
question qui peut paraître bête puisque
vous vous faites donc ces objets pour
déplacer des cartons des bacs ou des
palettes c'était quoi le problème à la
base avec le concept de caddie de
chariot à la limite de transpalette
assistance électrique en fait faut
savoir que les robots que nous
produisons sont faits pour bosser de
manière collaborative avec les gens nous
on fait ça pour les gens et avec eux
je sais pas si c'est bien pour des gens
de pousser simplement et de tirer des
chariots avec des pièces dessus je pense
que c'est plus intelligent de leur faire
faire des choses avec plus de valeur
ajoutée donc et puis en voilà en tirant
moins de charges en portant moins de
charges ça sert à ça en fait la
robotique mobile il faut savoir aussi
que on écoute aussi nos clients il y a
nos clients qui nous disent nous on
trouve plus personne les chariots rouges
on trouve plus personne pour pour mettre
pour conduire des fleurs fourches on
trouve plus personne pour refaire pour
pousser pour tirer des chariots il y a
aussi ça donc on écoute aussi nos
clients quoi
ça vient aussi de l'écoute client ce
qu'on a proposé comme comme produit on a
juste pas fait comme ça pour nous mais
après vous avez forcément enfin une
équipe d'ingénieurs qui sont extrêmement
brillants vigilant parce que j'ai
regardé les vidéos et c'est vraiment
très impressionnant mais voilà est-ce
que c'est pas possible de mettre ses
cerveaux et cette innovation dans
justement une amélioration de la
technologie de base qui est très sobre
et de l'améliorer de la meilleure de la
meilleure manière possible c'est sûr que
on pousse nos ingénieurs à faire de la
techno la plus simple possible voilà
mais on les pousse à faire ça
nous on
travaille beaucoup l'apprentissage on a
beaucoup développé l'apprentissage chez
nous on prend des des ingénieurs qui
sortent d'écoles on est on prend des
apprentis de l'alternance et
on essaye de leur voilà de leur
inculquer ses valeurs oui on veut pas
faire de la tech compliqué on de faire
le texte simple mais il y a aussi des
normes qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
absolument tenir
par exemple freiner un robot c'est pas
juste mettre comme les vélos de l'époque
un tampon sur le frein c'est la norme ne
le permet plus quoi c'est plus possible
il faut que on mesure en permanence la
vitesse de décélération pour vérifier
que ça décélère mais c'est il y a aussi
des normes donc on est obligé de se
conformer assez énorme donc c'est une
question pas simple c'est une question
intéressante mais pas simple je vous
remercie donc il y a un nouveau
phénomène qui prend de plus en place
autour de nous c'est l'écho anxiété donc
c'est une anxiété qui est nourrie par
les crises et les catastrophes
environnementales et cette incapacité de
se projeter dans dans notre avenir
d'après la Fondation Jean Jaurès il y a
74% des moins de 25 ans qui jugent
l'avenir effrayant donc forcément il y a
pas que la question de réchauffement
climatique mais face à ça il y a tout le
monde qui va pas réagir de la même
manière donc il y a forcément celles et
ceux qui ont envie d'agir il y a une
énorme partie qui sont dépassé désespéré
s voir do Miss et qui abandonne tout
espoir de sauver quoi que ce soit donc
juste pour avoir une idée qui dans cette
salle a déjà été anxieuse face à
l'avenir
voilà ok donc je suis pas monsieur
Jean-Côme ici niveau hors de grandeur je
dirais qu'on a quasiment l'intégralité
de la pièce sans prendre trop de risques
comment
soucieux ouais mais après voilà ça c'est
le reste de ma question je vais
commencer à vous la poser monsieur
Charnay est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte est-ce que vous rendiez compte de
l'ampleur du phénomène et surtout de la
gravité en fait du terme anxieux
si j'ai abandonné un poste qui me
passionnait en Supply et j'ai voulu
faire du développement durable c'est
bien parce que j'ai quelque chose qui me
trotte dans la tête maintenant il faut
faire avec et le parti que j'ai pris moi
c'est de foncer de faire des projets et
de faire du mieux possible et puis on
verra au Sunway mais je suis pas
sociologue et je sais pas répondre de
manière plus profonde à cette question
c'est une question
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est une question compliquée parce
que moi aussi j'ai trois garçons de vos
âges là
c'est clair que on voit tous que cette
anxiété grandit fortement vraiment
fortement c'est une question de répondre
adresser à Monsieur Jean-Côme ici parce
que je suis intéressé de sa réponse
je vois que ça engendre des violences et
des aussi des raisonnements irrationnels
moi c'est surtout ça qui me rend anxieux
parce que il y a des violences que je
comprends pas mais mais je ne suis pas
sociologue non plus j'ai pas la réponse
non plus je serais curieux d'avoir la
réponse de Monsieur Jean-Paul ici
le meilleur façon de je pense que
personne ne peut
ignorer l'anxiété qu'il y a autour et je
pense que tout le monde est voilà il y a
des sujets dont on parlait peu il y a 5
ans ou assez qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il y a plus personne qui qui n'a pas
entendu le mot climat ou environnement
ou dans sa journée donc voilà ils sont
sur la table donc personne peut ignorer
l'anxiété moi les enfants aussi un peu
plus jeunes que les autres mais je
voulais juste pisser l'exemple ma fille
et assez plutôt dans elle est plutôt
décroissante ma fille là pour répondre à
la question de la croissance parce que
voilà 14 ans et puis à Noël je demandais
ce qu'elle voulait elle m'a dit bah j'ai
besoin de rien
14 ans elle est pas je passe à 14 ans
que mon disait ça et j'y mets toujours
pas un jean elle m'a dit mais j'en ai
déjà un et tu sais combien il faut dos
pour faire un jean elle me dit genre
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire que oui il va falloir
que je m'en aille dans trois minutes
parce que après je vais aller m'occuper
de la puissance publique
je vais à l'ISP après donc voilà
toujours pour le même genre de numéro de
plaquettes et non ce que je voulais dire
c'est que il y a un sondage qui a une
étude assez détaillée qui vient d'être
publié par RTE et qui a été faite par
Ipsos sur les Français face à la
sobriété alors en fait ils sont
particulièrement concentrés sur deux
usages qui sont électrifiables donc
évidemment c'est sur cela que RTE avait
demandé qu'on pose plein de questions
qui sont le logement et les transports
mais ils ont également posé des
questions sur est-ce que les gens
croient ou croient pas que le
réchauffement climatique aura existe
puis est d'origine anthropique est-ce
que ils ont confiance en l'avenir pas
confiance en l'avenir etc et j'ai été
très surpris en lisant une partie des
résultats parce que à nouveau j'ai
retrouvé quelque chose qui est qu'il n'y
a pas d'effet de classe d'âge alors que
là on vient de dire qu'il y a l'exact
inverse et mon sentiment c'est qu'en
fait l'effet de classe d'âge je dis pas
du tout ça pour faire de la sociologie à
deux balles mais je pense que il est
très présent chez les CSP plus je pense
que l'effet le basage il joue beaucoup
beaucoup sur les gens qui sont à l'aise
économiquement et qui jouent beaucoup
moins chez les gens qui sont plus
modestes alors deux résultats moi qui
m'ont frappé le taux de gens qui disent
ou le changement climatique ça n'existe
pas où il existe mais il est pas
d'origine humaine etc et légèrement plus
élevé chez les jeunes que chez les vieux
si on prend l'ensemble de la classe
d'âge la deuxième chose c'est que si on
demande aux gens est-ce que vous êtes
anxieux face à l'avenir toutes les
classes d'âge sont très majoritairement
répondent oui et il y a juste 2% de
différence 2% entre les 15 24 ans et les
60 69 ans certes les gens de ma classe
d'âge ils sont pas
significativement moins anxieux face à
l'avenir que votre fille plus un an
voilà donc c'était deux résultats que je
voulais partager avec vous parce que et
par contre ce que m'a dit alors il faut
que je connais très bien le
prospectiviste en chef de RTE qui
s'appelle Thomas verenc et ils n'ont pas
rendu public
je crois comprendre pourquoi la
segmentation des réponses en fonction
des préférences partisanales parce que
si ils ont sondé 11000 personnes et pas
1000 tous les gens dans cette salle qui
ont fait trois trois bouts de
statistiques savent que c'est parce que
ils veulent avoir des résultats
significatifs en croisant trois critères
et pas deux parce que si vous faites sur
1000 personnes dès que vous croisez
trois critères vous avez deux personnes
dans une catégorie 3 etc donc ça n'a 0 6
0 signification statistique
et mon Paris résultat mais mon Paris
c'est que il y a également une
différenciation très forte en fonction
de la préférence partisane de la réponse
à ces questions
voilà et là-dessus merci d'avoir
organisé ça et bonne fin d'après-midi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai quand même une dernière
petite question alors c'est vrai que
face à ce phénomène des corps anxiété on
remarque souvent chez les jeunes que de
plus en plus de jeunes diplômés
abandonnent idée de toute de grandes
carrières dans leur domaine d'études et
des sites finalement de bifurquer vers
d'autres domaines donc là je parle ici
de
bifurcation écologique et donc
finalement c'est le c'est le refus
d'être complice face à la face à la
création de de projets qui vont
consister à détruire des espaces riches
en biodiversité et ou augmenter la part
d'énergie fossile donc ma première
question c'est est-ce que c'est un
phénomène que de manière un peu résumer
finalement c'est la relève qui ne veut
plus être la relève quoi enfin pour être
un peu plus pour résumer un peu plus
donc est-ce que c'est déjà un phénomène
que vous avez
ressenti et si oui est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous craignez et qui
pourrait vous faire revoir votre plan
votre plan d'organisation quoi
merci pour cette question
alors
il n'y a pas de réponse il y a pas une
réponse monolithique à votre question le
question de la question de la carrière
elle touche pas que l'engagement climat
pas climat elle touche c'est plus
générationnel et d'ailleurs pas si
générationnel que ça non plus mais on a
de plus en plus de gens qui sont plus du
tout intéressés par le parcours de
carrière pendant 20 ans etc ça n'existe
plus trop mais qui sont qui sont
vraiment à la recherche de qu'est-ce qui
fait sens pour eux qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire de leur temps qu'est-ce
que en quoi ils ont envie de mettre leur
énergie etc etc et puis c'est des
considérations qu'on peut avoir beaucoup
plus effectivement comme ça a été dit
dans les CSP+ on a le choix ou on est
très éduqué
on a beaucoup moins ces critères là ces
états d'âme là sur certaines populations
d'opérateurs par exemple etc
par contre après on je pense qu'il faut
aussi pas tomber dans le piège de de
dire par exemple on veut pas être
complice de en l'occurrence chaque choix
qui est fait qu'on fait qu'on peut faire
en tant que consommateur peut rendre
complice de quelque chose donc ce soit
il faut avoir un choix vraiment engagé
dire moi je veux bosser pour une ONG
mais je vais être congruant dans toutes
mes décisions j'achète pas des Nike
faites à votre bout du monde je prends
pas l'avion pour aller acheter ça à sac
à main Desigual à Barcelone et j'achète
pas du chat quoi donc il change pas de
téléphone je change pas de smartphone
des Apple on sort un nouveau quoi donc
je trouve qu'il y a aussi la question de
la congruence et le et de la
responsabilité
et je pense qu'il vaut mieux mettre
l'énergie et l'intelligence qu'on a au
service de comment je peux avoir un
impact on peut l'avoir dans une régime
on peut aussi l'avoir dans une dans une
entreprise plus traditionnelle dans une
industrie etc on peut même peut-être
avoir plus d'impact en essayant
transformer cette industrie plutôt que
de se dire je me sauve et puis je me dis
que je fais un truc un peu plus green
enfin je dis pas que c'est le cas mais
ça peut aussi être le piège c'est à dire
que vous vous envoyez dans votre enquête
c'est les colas c'est les consommateurs
qui doivent changer c'est les
entreprises doivent changer les pouvoirs
publics doivent prendre la mesure de la
gravité de la situation et c'est juste
si tous l'écosystème se met en marche
qu'on y arrive il s'agirait pas
d'opposer les uns les méchants
industriels ou les horribles brasseurs
qui assèchent l'adapte phréatique et les
méchants industriels etc mais à
l'inverse de dire on entend aussi ce
discours de dire oh c'est d'écolo
ils nous emmerde mais non mais va en
fait il faut pas opposer sinon sinon on
est dans une inaction assez forte quoi
donc voilà ça c'est juste voilà pour ce
qu'on fait la fresque du climat ça peut
aussi référer à haut triangle de
l'inaction donc c'est tout le monde qui
se rejette la faute et au final ça
n'avance pas personne n'agit
un mot là dessus tu as tout dit
mais alors pour cette dernière question
je sais qu'il s'agit d'une table ronde
mais permettez-moi de quitter la table
parce que cette question est concerne
absolument tout le monde dans cette
salle mais également les personnes qui
nous regardent derrière leurs écrans
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à toutes les
entreprises donc celles qui sont
présentes ici aujourd'hui et je vais
vous nommer
on a socome qu'on a libéré
question ici mais ça serait ça
littéralement toutes les entreprises
dans dans notre secteur du BTP de
l'industrie
pour certains d'entre vous on nous a
pointé du doigt on vous a dénoncé
parfois même on vous a confronté et si
je vous nomme aujourd'hui c'est pas
parce que je suis là pour vous blâmer on
a vraiment on a vraiment plus le temps
pour ça monsieur Jean-Côme tout à
l'heure si je vous nomme aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je suis là pour vous
inviter non je suis là pour vous
convoquer sur le plus grand chantier du
siècle je suis là pour vous convoquer
sur la restructuration territoriale à
l'échelle nationale je vous convoque
pour réaliser la nouvelle révolution
industrielle qui se doit d'être sobre et
résiliente je vous convoque sur le
chantier de du développement massif
de ferroviaire tout en prenant en compte
la transformation et la transformation
pardon de nos modes de déplacement tout
en prenant en compte la question de la
biodiversité et des lignes déjà
existantes je vous convoque sur le
chantier de la rénovation énergétique
est thermique des bâtiments tant dans le
résidentiel que dans le tertiaire je
vous convoque sur la réparation de nos
réseaux hydraoniques hydrauliques pardon
et gazier pour réduire drastiquement les
fuites qui aujourd'hui représentent
des enfin une perte faramineuse de ses
ressources je vous convoque sur la
transformation du secteur
agro-industriel pour permettre à la
biodiversité et à la terre de se
restaurer et d'en finir avec l'élevage
intensif qui représente aujourd'hui la
quasi intégralité des émissions de ce
secteur je vous convoque sur le chantier
dans l'aménagement du territoire d'un
urbanisme pour faire face aux vagues de
chaleur qui sont de plus en plus
intenses et de plus en plus longues et
qui sont aujourd'hui meurtrières
je vous convoque sur tous ces chantiers
toutes ces restructurations qui nous
permettront de maintenir
une qualité de vie un confort de vie
tout en maintenant nos droits au
déplacement aux loisirs au voyage
auxquels on tient tout ce temps mais
surtout pour me permettre le droit et
l'accès aux ressources vitales comme
l'eau et la nourriture ça aujourd'hui en
France c'est déjà compromis
alors on entend trop souvent dire de la
part de personnes qui ne veulent pas
agir l'humain s'est adapté il s'adaptera
oui la natation elle est maintenant
l'adaptation elle est territoriale
l'adaptation elle est structurelle et
l'adaptation elle est pérenne mais
l'adaptation on y arrivera pas sans un
effort coûte que coûte et surtout cette
adaptation on n'y arrivera pas sans vous
alors pour revenir à ma question aux
entreprises
vous permettez
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à bifurquer
avec nous
merci
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que est-ce que vous les jeunes et
tout vous êtes prêts à venir nous aider
à le faire aussi avec grand plaisir avec
en prévision
alors je vous remercie pour cet échange
et pour voilà de vous êtes confrontés à
Monsieur Jean covici et à des jeunes
avec des idées
et on espère pouvoir partager ces idées
et nos valeurs pour construire un monde
meilleur parce que c'est ce qu'on nous
vend en venant à l'INSA et c'est ce
qu'on espère sincèrement pouvoir faire
et voilà c'est encore une fois on n'est
pas dans le choc générationnel on a
besoin tous des uns des autres on est
jeune on est peut-être plus voilà plus
extraverti on va peut-être porter les
idées plus plus fort mais c'est parce
qu'on a vraiment besoin là c'est
littéralement une question de vie ou de
mort et on a besoin de vous et donc on
espère pouvoir vous aider aussi merci
[Applaudissements]